messieurs nous poursuivons cet
après-midi les travaux de notre
commission d'enquête par l'audition à
nouveau de Madame Audrey dervalois
présidente de sanovie France
accompagné de monsieur Jean-Yves Moreau
et de Monsieur Philippe charrot c'est ça
je vous remercie de plus vous êtes
mobilisés madame la Présidente que c'est
la deuxième fois que nous vous entendons
nous vous êtes accompagné donc par
Monsieur Philippe charro vice-président
à faire industriel France et Monsieur
donc Jean-Yves Moreau c'est en effet à
la politique industrielle de votre
groupe que sera consacré cette audition
après celle du 12 avril au cours de
laquelle vous nous aviez détaillé votre
stratégie globale
Sanofi constitue un fleuron de
l'industrie française c'est même le
premier groupe national du point de vue
de la dépense de recherche et
développement tout comme la première du
secteur pharmaceutique européen Suisse
excepté l'actualité récente a d'ailleurs
apporté plusieurs exemples de réussite
de cette investissement je pense
notamment à l'annonce le 12 mai dernier
de résultat prometteurs concernant un
anticorps monoclonal que vous développez
avec AstraZeneca et qui permet de
réduire de
83%, les hospitalisations liées au virus
respiratoire synchiscial responsable de
la majorité des cas de bronchiolite et
de 50000 hospitalisations chaque année
vous nous direz si comme je l'espère ce
vaccin bien que le terme soit un peu
raccourci et un propre sera disponible
pour l'automne prochain et dans quelles
conditions notamment de prix de même la
FDA vient de donner son feu vert à un
nouveau traitement contre l'hémophilie
la tulleview j'espère que je l'ai bien
prononcé dans une
soit des principes actifs anciens qui ne
répondent plus aux besoins des patients
grâce à l'arrivée de nouveaux
traitements vous comprendrez outre son
coût social on le contexte de la lutte
contre la trop grande dépendance à
l'écart des pays asiatiques dans la
fabrication de ces principes actifs
cette décision interroge surtout deux
ans après la session d'euro API
entreprise désormais dédiée à la
production des principes actifs
pharmaceutiques pour des tiers
vous nous direz pourquoi cette nouvelle
réorganisation intervient aujourd'hui et
si vous avez examiné l'hypothèse de
produire d'autres principes actifs
notamment pour des médicaments qui
connaissent ou ont connu des tensions ou
des ruptures d'approvisionnement y
compris en bénéficiant d'un soutien
financier de la part de l'État sur
l'ensemble de ces sujets madame la
Présidente je vais vous céder la parole
pour un bref propos introductif puis
madame Laurence Cohen rapporteur de
notre commission d'enquête vous posera
une première série de questions je
précise que cette audition est diffusée
en direct sur le site internet du Sénat
comme vous le savez désormais et qu'elle
fera l'objet d'un compte-rendu publié
avant de vous donner la parole je vous
rappelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête est passive
des peines prévues aux articles 434-13
432-14 et 434-15 du code pénal et je
vous invite chacun à votre tour à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité en levant la main droite en
disant je ne jure madame derveloy
je le jure monsieur Moreau
la présidente Madame la rapporteur
mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs alors on entre production et
en complément de ce que nous avons pu
présenter vous l'avez rappeler lors de
la commission du 12 avril notamment sur
les leviers pour faire face aux tensions
mondiale du médicament et les nouvelles
capacités de production en France et en
Europe je vous remercie de nous donner
l'occasion de repartager avec vous les
grandes lignes de notre stratégie
industrielle et notamment sur nos
activités de la production alors je vais
vous partager les grands principes les
grands défis auxquels nous faisons face
et puis aussi certaines spécificités de
branches qui vont couvrir un certain
nombre de sujets que vous venez
d'évoquer donc les cinq grands principes
stratégies industriels chez Sanofi pour
nos 16 sites en France nos 36 en Europe
qui forment un parc mondial de 59 sites
repose sur cinq éléments
un élément clé c'est l'adaptation
permanente à la dynamique des produits
au regard des besoins médicaux des
patients et ses besoins médicaux
évoluent sans cesse avec notamment vous
l'avez souligné à des produits nouveaux
innovants mais aussi des produits plus
anciens nécessaires au patients qui ont
finalement des demandes qui évoluent à
la hausse ou à la baisse et donc nous
cherchons toujours à anticiper au
maximum ses besoins sur un segment
dynamique deuxième principe important
pour nous la recherche continue
d'excellence sur nos sites industriels
et Monsieur Charo pourrait y revenir
pour avoir sans cesse le meilleur dans
nos usines le meilleur des technologies
mais également la digitalisation
force aussi de constater que chez Sanofi
nous avons une spécificité avec des
produits pharmaceutiques et aussi des
vaccins nous cherchons à avoir un réseau
plus intégré et ça fait partie de notre
transformation industrielle deux autres
éléments que je voudrais citer dans les
principes de notre transformation une
accélération vers la décarbonation et
donc nous engageons pleinement à avoir
un plan d'industrie plus verte et
également d'expliquer à nous avons
besoin de davantage dans la pédagogie et
notamment avec un dialogue social pour
expliquer ces évolutions
c'est grand principe ne sont pas
déconnectés de notre environnement
mondial et bien évidemment nous avons
déjà évoqué certains grands défis liés
aux crises récentes et je tiens à
souligner que ces défis ne se
substituent pas les uns aux autres mais
malheureusement ils s'empile comme un
mille-feuille et donc aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans une vraie complexité
industrielle pour le groupe Sanofi en
France et vous l'avez évoqué donc il y a
six grands défis sur lesquels je
voudrais très rapidement revenir un
l'impact sur la compétitivité de nos
sites liés à l'inflation surtout les
composants mais je reviens pas on en a
déjà parlé de la dernière fois mais
toutes les zones géographiques
aujourd'hui ne subissent pas cette
inflation de la même façon
deuxièmement nous avons une exposition
très importante sur la volatilité des
volumes notamment en Chine ou sur
certaines erres thérapeutiques puisqu'on
nous avons un portefeuille de médecine
générale relativement conséquent la
Chine est notre deuxième marché mondial
la médecine générale et des premiers
marchés pour certains de nos sites
industriels euh ceux qui les exposent
fortement et notamment la médecine
générale est en retrait de 4,2%. donc
nous avons fait le choix et nous en
sommes fiers d'avoir choisi la France
pour produire nos médicaments dans le
monde que nous exportons et bien
évidemment nous sommes aussi impactés
par ces tendances mondiales et nous les
subissons un troisième élément important
dans ces défis c'est la montée en
puissance des bioséminaires sur le
marché mondial après les génériques dans
les années 2000 nous voyons des impacts
à l'exemple de notre principe que
l'examenox son traitement contre les
thromboses avec trois sites en France
donc l'un exporte plus de 70% de ses
produits avec des volumes encore une
fois en baisse de 15%. je tiens à
souligner que typiquement nous avons dû
fermer notre site de rue de cheval
Richfield pardon aux États-Unis puisque
nous ont perdu le marché américain
quatrième grand défi le ralentissement
des volumes de vaccins sur certains
marchés étrangers
alors qu'encore une fois nos sites
français exportent une grande partie de
leur volume et nous avons comme vous
avez vu dans l'écosystème des nouveaux
concurrents notamment sur l'ARN messager
et je reviendrai c'était un des sujets
que vous avez évoqué maintenant de ma
présence cinquième défi complexité
accrue opérationnel ces dernières années
avec des petites séries ou des
présentations particulières de
médicaments et donc là nous devons aussi
nous adapter et le dernier une évolution
des compétences des nouveaux métiers des
nouveaux besoins et certaines
compétences feront l'objet de formation
continue avec des mises en place de
parcours professionnels et donc nous
nous adaptons à ces nouveaux besoins et
je tiens à souligner que typiquement 300
recrutements sont prévus en 2023 pour
répondre à ces nouveaux besoins alors
sur cette base des cinq principes et de
ces six grands défis majeurs et mondiaux
notre stratégie industrielle répond
encore une fois pour les besoins des
médicaments
et ses besoins médicaux pardon autour de
trois branches et juste je voudrais
prendre quelques minutes pour spécifier
certains points
sur la branche vaccin nous ambitionnons
de maintenir notre souveraineté avec les
technologies existantes donc sur la
grippe notamment nous sommes leader
mondial sur des vaccins de combinaison
pédiatriques et j'y reviendrai vous avez
cité l'exemple de la ponctualité et donc
nous voulons rester vraiment leader sur
ces domaines en même temps nous voulons
être présent continuer à innover et
porter une nouvelle approche d'airl
messager vous l'avez également souligné
donc nous adaptons et nos ressources de
façon cohérente à cette stratégie sur la
branche vaccin je me permets de reciter
des exemples sur les investissements qui
sont faits actuellement sur cette
branche vaccin dans la région lyonnaise
935 millions d'euros entre 2022 et 2026
pour avoir cette chaîne d'ARN messager
au niveau de Marcy-l'Étoile
490 millions d'euros pour la
construction d'une nouvelle
usine évolutive à Neuville-sur-Saône
mais également 120 millions d'euros pour
un nouveau bâtiment de recherche et
développement vaccin à Marcy-l'Étoile
à l'inverse moins de besoin encore une
fois lié aux besoins des patients mais
aussi des professionnels de santé par
exemple sur des formes lyophilisées où
nous devons adapter nos besoins pour
aller plus vers des formes liquides
prêtes à l'emploi donc typiquement nous
optimisons nos activités entre nos sites
européens sur sur ce type de sujet par
exemple
deuxième spécificité de branche la
branche bioproduction donc c'est ce
qu'on appelle chez nous les grosses
molécules donc notamment avec les
anticorps monoclonaux que nous avons à
Vitry là aussi à nous devons améliorer
notre rendement réduire les coûts de
production et réfléchir à une approche
plus globalisée saisir les opportunités
de recherche avec l'écosystème français
et nous travaillons notamment avec 6
centres enfin si je suis dans des
réseaux hospitaliers universitaires pour
nos produits prioritaires je termine
avec la branche chimie puisque vous
aviez des questions sur cette partie
chimique nécessite d'athénie unifier et
nous avons trois tendances sur cette
branche chimie anticipée anticiper les
nouveaux besoins demain liés à notre
portefeuille recentrer et rationaliser
je dis anticiper parce que nous devons
se préparer au lancement industriel des
futurs molécules de synthèse du groupe
notamment en neurologie dans la sclérose
en plaques
mais pas que dans les maladies type
fabriquent gaucher ou thrombocytopénie
immune et nous espérons avoir oui
nouvelle molécules dans le pipeline qui
pourront notamment être produites en
France nous investissons pour cela
puisque nous devons encore une fois être
prêt en avance pourquoi produire ses
produits et c'est un exemple que j'avais
pu citer lors de la précédente audition
avec le lancement de l'unité de petits
volumes assisteront où nous avons fait
un investissement de 60 millions pour
être prêts sur ces petites molécules en
parallèle nous devons nous recentrer et
sécuriser l'avenir des usines françaises
pour les produits de médecine générale à
forte valeur ajoutée et donc là on se
focalise notamment sur les médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur et les
médicaments classés par l'OMS comme
médicament essentiel mais aussi répondre
à des appels d'offres internationaux
puisque je rappelle que nous avons fait
le choix de la France pour produire les
médicaments pour le groupe
et dernière partie rationalisée parce
que ça fait aussi partie de notre
stratégie industrielle de pouvoir aussi
faire des transmettre transferts
hautement qualitatif avec des groupes et
là j'aimerais insister uniquement
français et européen que nous
accompagnons et notamment nous avons des
activités d'accompagnement des
repreneurs et on assure à minima 3 ans
de production ceci dans un but d'avoir
une pertinence respective de
portefeuille nous avons besoin de tous
les acteurs des plus petits et des plus
grands et donc c'est une source de
croissance aussi pour les plus petits
laboratoires de récupérer ces
portefeuilles avec des stratégies par
exemple dans la douleur ou dans la santé
de la femme mais aussi ça permet la
pérennité de la mise à disposition
auprès des patients un mot sur Aramon et
Sisteron puisque je crois que vous avez
fait écho de ces sujets dans la presse
aussi il y a actuellement je sais que
Monsieur Charo pourrait revenir sur vos
questions à des sous occupations de
certains bâtiments de production parfois
à moins de 30% des bâtiments qui sont
obsolètes et une tension importante en
parallèle sur d'autres donc nous avons
besoin d'avoir une branche chimie
unifiée recentrée et qui répondent
encore une fois besoin des patients
demain on pourra prendre vos questions
plus détaillées en conclusion les
adaptations permanentes de notre outil
industriel industriel sont donc
absolument nécessaires il en va notre
responsabilité pour garantir la
souveraineté sanitaire aujourd'hui mais
également demain et nous voulons
absolument avoir des investissements qui
répondent de façon cohérente à cette
stratégie on a eu plusieurs fois
l'occasion de partager ces
investissements qui sont absolument
massifs entre 300 et 400 millions
d'investissements tous les ans sur nos
sites et ceux qui positionne Sanofi en
France au service des patients je tiens
à en profiter encore une fois pour
rappeler les efforts de nos
collaborateurs français vous avez pu le
découvrir lors de la visite de Lisieux
les efforts qui ont été faits sur le
doliprane en France sont absolument
exceptionnels et n'ont jamais été aussi
fort pour sano nous avons pu doter les
patients français de 424 millions de
boîtes et je parle de boîtes pas de
comprimés c'est important de noter la
différence pour répondre à cette triple
épidémie cet hiver c'est une
mobilisation qui a été absolument
incroyable la France a été priorisé et
je me permets de le ressouler à ce titre
nos usines également en Allemagne et en
Italie ont permis aux patients français
d'avoir des capacités supérieures cet
hiver enfin Sanofi est une entreprise
française vous l'avez souligné
européenne et mondial elle est avant
tout française parce qu'avec seulement
4% de son chiffre d'affaires en France
on y emploie 20% de nos effectifs
chiffres stables dans le temps
on déduit 40% de notre appareil
industriel et 35% notre recherche notre
président ex président assigné à cette
semaine à l'Assemblée Générale en 50 ans
sanofi a été une succession
d'acquisition plus de 300 dont les plus
connus sentaient labo johnsheim Aventis
mais la taille n'est pas un atout en soi
si on est qu'une addition d'entité c'est
pour soi nous sommes absolument
responsables de poursuivre ce travail
déficience d'harmonisation sur
l'ensemble de nos activités pour le
groupe pour préparer les 50 prochaines
années qui nous permettront d'être au
service des patients en français dans le
monde je vous remercie pour votre
attention et nous sommes disponibles
pour répondre à vos questions
je vous remercie et je passe
immédiatement la parole à Madame
Laurence socoenne rapporteur
oui merci Madame pour ces précisions
donc comme l'a dit notre Présidente
c'est une commission d'enquête donc nous
vous posons des questions précises et
nous avons besoin d'avoir des réponses
précises d'où le fait que nous vous
ayons demandé effectivement de revenir
puisque le 12 avril 2023 nous vous avons
auditionné madame en compagnie
d'ailleurs également de Madame Clotilde
Jolivet et de Monsieur Jean-Marc Lacroix
et notamment vous avez répondu un
certain nombre de de nos questions celle
de mes collègues et de moi-même et je
vous ai notamment interrogé sur l'avenir
du site de production de cisteron et
madame je vous relis mes propos le site
de cisteron est emblématique de la
chimie pharmaceutique de demain or le
bâtiment dans lequel Sanofi investit n'a
pas l'activité escompté par manque de
molécules est-ce que c'est réel ou pas
c'est exactement la question je vous
avais posée et Madame Clotilde Jolivet
m'a répondu en disant qu'effectivement
elle avait besoin de vérifier
l'information il peut y avoir un
bâtiment qui est qui soit qui est en
moindre activité que d'autres mais je
n'ai pas d'information en tête donc on
peut voilà on reçoit évidemment cette
réponse et elle continue par contre
c'est un site sur lequel on a investi
notamment pour cette nouvelle unité de
lancement mais c'est un site qui a
bénéficié d'investissement
c'est 60 millions d'euros sur plusieurs
années on est vraiment convaincu qu'il y
a là la capacité les compétences pour
faire de belles choses de produits en
chimie issus de notre recherche et
développement de notre collaboration
donc il y a vraiment un potentiel
et vous même madame veloy vous avez
ajouté si vous voulez je les chiffres
des informations sur Sisteron on a 600
collaborateurs sur le site cisteron 120
en RRD 480 en affaires industrielle et
produit aujourd'hui le
télébrutinibe médicament contre la
sclérose en plaques 25 millions d'euros
ont été investis en 2021 et les
principaux projets sont les lancements
petit volume et le développement de
procédés chimiques continuent par
microfluidique or le lendemain le jeudi
13 avril 2023 lors d'un comité social et
économique extraordinaire les salariés
ont appris la suppression de 135 postes
d'ici 2025 sur les 6 les sites d'Aramont
Mourenx et de cisteron ce qui
s'accompagnerait éventuellement de la
démolition d'un atelier de production de
principes actifs représentant d'après le
syndicat CGT une perte de capacité de
production de plus de 50 tonnes de es
actifs et la presse quotidienne
régionale son effet l'écho le journal La
Provin la Provence indiquant dans son
papier du 17 avril que Madame devers
directrice du site de cisteron avait
prévenu la mairie de Sisteron le 7 avril
2023 soit 5 jours avant votre audition
alors à partir de là j'ai quatre
questions à vous poser
comment est-ce possible qu'au moment de
l'audition que auquel vous avez
participé à laquelle vous avez participé
vous n'ayez pas eu la connaissance des
suppressions de poste sur les sites
c'est ma première question ma deuxième
quelle est la définition pour Sanofi je
cite d'un potentiel où il y a la
capacité et les compétences pour faire
de belles choses puisque cela signifie
de réduire le personnel et donc de
réduire les capacités de production
vous comprendrez bien que ça nous
intéresse parce que qui dit réduction
des capacités de production dit
possibilité de médicaments en tension
c'est l'objet même de notre de notre
commission d'enquête enfin le toujours
le 13 avril j'avais conclu en indiquant
que la question était précise donc il
fallait des réponses précises que
derrière les investissements financiers
est-ce qu'il n'y avait pas la volonté de
valoriser l'outil industriel pour la
revente ou pour véritablement améliorer
les capacités de production de
médicaments dans notre pays on est
on a besoin de comprendre quel est votre
votre stratégie
et ma quatrième question c'est que vous
avez notamment justifié cette diminution
d'effectif par le fait que les principes
actifs impactés par cette décision sont
soit et je crois que la présidente la
souligné les productions pour tiers dans
la demande diminue au fil du temps soit
des principes actifs anciens qui ne
répondent plus aux besoins des patients
grâce à l'arrivée de nouveaux
traitements
donc quels sont ces principes dont vous
abandonnez la production
est-ce qu'il est vrai que cela concerne
notamment l'amoxicilline dont la pénurie
a marqué les esprits au cours de l'hiver
dernier et alors que les pédiates de 5
pays européens dont la France ont déjà
tiré la sonnette d'alarme pour l'hôtel
pour l'automne prochain pardon et c'est
assez paradoxal puisque le gouvernement
cherche à grand renfort d'être public à
relocaliser des activités de chimie
destinées à la production pharmaceutique
on a donc peine à comprendre qu'on se
prive de capacité de production qui
existe déjà je vous remercie
je vous remercie pour les questions qui
sont claires et précises donc je vais
essayer d'y répondre le plus précisément
possible donc sur effectivement votre
première question est sur le calendrier
donc je laisserai monsieur Charo
expliquer le process de dialogue avec
les représentants des instances qui ont
sont sous un mode projet et donc tu
pourras expliquer
encore une fois de nos
stratégie industrielle je voulais
rappeler elle répond à des besoins et
elle s'inscrit dans un système
d'adaptation et c'est vraiment ça qu'on
veut faire c'est on adapte notre outil
industriel pour qu'il reste performant
et qui soit au meilleur avec les
meilleures technologies de pointe donc
je vais je peux pas faire la parole
physique pour y répondre sur notamment
les capacités et les autres questions
merci merci pour vos questions alors
déjà je voudrais raffiner quelque chose
qui est qui est important pour Sanofi
c'est que la chimie la chimie de
synthèse la chimie pharmaceutique c'est
une plateforme technologique clé pour
Sanofi
pour deux raisons la première c'est
qu'elle permet de soutenir on va dire
des produits des grands produits
historiques de la maison on peut citer
bien sûr plavix on peut citer
on peut citer à provel on peut citer
muletac ou des parkings et d'autres
encore et également ce sont des c'est
une technologie absolument clé pour
maîtriser des futurs lancements comme
interlois a mentionné et je me fais pour
répondre à une de vos questions sur le
l'utilisation de la capacité de du LPV
je tiens à vous rassurer tout de suite
lorsque l'on regarde le pipeline de
Sanofi ne pas être lame connu parce que
vous savez qu'aussi certaines molécules
arrivent dans notre pipeline de R&D via
des acquisitions quand on regarde
simplement le piclan actuel de notre R&D
la capacité utilisée dans le fameux ulpv
et tout à fait bonne dans les années à
venir donc pas de sujet j'ai pas de j'ai
pas de souci j'ajouterai d'ailleurs que
le le concept même de ce bâtiment c'est
un bâtiment de lancement et qu'en fait
les produits s'ils se développent
correctement n'ont pas ne devrait pas
rester très longtemps quelques années
tout au plus et lorsque les volumes
seront suffisants ils seront dans une
autre unité sur le site de Sisteron ou
sur le site d'Aramon de façon à laisser
de la place dans cette unité qui est
encore une fois et et conçu pour
accompagner le lancement industriel du
produit pour les premières années de
lancement donc la chimie c'est une
plateforme technologique clé pour Sanofi
pour ces deux pour ces deux raisons
insupporter de le portefeuille de
produits nature et le grand produit de
la maison et puis soutenir les
lancements industriels par contre
effectivement comme le noter madame
derlebois dervallois on a on a dans le
cycle de vie de nos produits une
évolution de notre portefeuille et le
taux d'occupation de nos ateliers sur
les sur les sites d'aramans et Sisteron
est très variables on a des ateliers on
a des ateliers qui sont extrêmement
chargés d'autres ateliers qui le sont
peu et lorsque on se projette dans dans
l'avenir on voit une diminution d'un
certain nombre de
d'utilisation de l'utilisation de ces
ateliers donc c'est pour ça que ça peut
engendrer un problème de aussi de
compétitivité c'est pour ça la raison
pour laquelle on doit dép redéployer on
va dire nos capacités et surtout les
moderniser ce que je voulais revenir sur
le point que vous citez au niveau des
bâtiments que l'on va arrêter bon ces
bâtiments sont largement sous-utilisés
aujourd'hui et et le seront encore plus
à l'avenir mais surtout ils sont
complètement obsolètes le bâtiment qu'on
va démolir à Sisteron il a plus de 100
ans c'est le bâtiment le plus ancien du
site le bâtiment qu'on va démolir afin
qu'on va arrêter à Ramon parce que la
décision de démolition elle est pas
encore prise et elle arrivera de toute
façon pas avant 2026 2027
et le bâtiment donc on va arrêter à
Ramon il a plus de 50 ans donc ce sont
des bâtiments très très manuels et
obsolète
il représente que deux bâtiments sur les
14 que la fameuse plateforme chimie
comporte donc arrêtez ces bâtiments si
vous voulez ça répond à une logique
d'adaptation de Bluetooth industriel
parce que dans le même temps on investit
dans de nouvelles installations de façon
à avoir des installations beaucoup plus
automatisées digitalisées parce que le
continuum des données entre notre
recherche développement nous lancement
industriels et notre production
commerciale et devient de plus en plus
importante ça permet aussi d'accueillir
de nouvelles technologies dans le futur
l'analyse en ligne la chimie en continu
par exemple
et puis aussi plus respectueux notre
empreinte environnementale donc on a
cité quelques investissements bon lui
LPV qui 60 millions d'euros mais
également des extensions de capacité
pour un certain nombre de produits à
Ramon 12 millions d'euros pour augmenter
la capacité dire mes archantemps donc le
principe actif d'approvel 10 millions
d'euros de également d'investissement
prévu dans notre feuille de route pour
augmenter la capacité en clopidogrelle
donc le principe actif de plavix on a
également développé une ferme solaire un
rameau de je parlais de l'empreinte
environnementale 11 millions d'euros
d'investissement et puis je parlais de
la chimie en continu on prévoit 20
millions d'euros d'investissements dans
ces nouvelles technologies de de
production chimique donc vous voyez
c'est bien c'est bien une évolution on
va dire à la fois capacitaire et
technologique qui induit effectivement
l'arrêt d'un certain nombre de bâtiments
anciens et obsolètes et l'investissement
dans des nouveaux bâtiments et des
nouvelles technologies alors je tiens
également à vous rassurer c'était une de
vos questions on n'est pas du tout en
train de valoriser l'outil pour le
revendre c'est tout le contraire on est
en train d'ancrer la production chimique
de demain dans Sanofi
avec du coup cette plateforme qui sera
unifiée autour des sites de sisterons à
Ramon et Mourenx donc on aura une vraie
plateforme moderne et c'est encore une
fois ce qu'on veut rajeunir le parc et
pouvoir encore une fois s'adapter aux
besoins qui évoluent des patients est-ce
que j'ai répondu à vos questions madame
Cohen parce que vous avez d'autres sur
les quatre questions est-ce que j'ai
répondu à vos questions
donc écoutez moi moi je
j'ai du mal à saisir en fait évidemment
quand vous vous apportez des réponses ça
apparaît comme logique voilà vous me
parlez de bâtiment obsolète vous allez
donc 100 ans vous allez moderniser vous
allez
en créer la chimie demain en France
enfin c'est assez formidable et
idyllique mais si j'en viens à
l'audition à laquelle vous avez
participé madame c'était la veille de
l'annonce de licenciement c'était un
moment où je vous pose des questions
précises sur un site et des bâtiments ou
quand même il m'est répondu qu'il y a un
investissement de 60 millions d'euros je
ne peux pas croire ou penser que Sanofi
compte tenu de sa de sa capacité de de
tout ce que sanofie est en capacité de
produire et ce qui a été par la
Présidente je ne peux pas penser qu'il
n'y ait aucune anticipation et que
finalement vous découvririez
par voie de presse
ce qui se passe au niveau de ces
sites-là et je ne comprends pas
davantage mais je suis persuadée que
vous allez m'apporter des précisions qui
vont éclairer ma lanterne je ne
comprends pas davantage comment est-ce
que vous investissez pour une somme qui
n'est pas mineure
dans un bâtiment et que après au bout de
quelques temps au nom de l'adaptation
aux nouveaux besoins vous renonciez à ce
que vous avez fait j'ai du mal si vous
voulez à comprendre en quoi cet
investissement de 60 millions finalement
apparaît comme ne pas correspondre mais
peut-être que je n'ai pas eu voilà ça
c'est ma première question et ma
deuxième question parce que on est sur
des bâtiments
ma deuxième question quand même c'est
que à la clé malheureusement il y a des
licenciements et que des licenciements à
Sanofi il y a un vrai savoir-faire à
Sanofi
si si j'ai bien compris même la
rapporteur ce que vous voulez entendre
et je me permets de le reformuler est-ce
que le 12 avril devant la commission
d'enquête parlementaire ce qui a été dit
était juste et avéré où y a-t-il eu un
élément dans la nuit du 12 au 13 avril
qui a pu manifester et justifier les
annonces du 13 avril est-ce que ma
question est claire madame
la rapporteur aussi je me permets de
rappeler aussi que ce jour-là j'ai
recherché dans mes notes puisque je vous
ai dit que j'étais pas non plus une
experte de industrielle que j'ai rejoins
le groupe il y a quelques mois et j'ai
lu je pense qu'on peut voir les images
j'ai sorti la fiche et je vous lui ai lu
les éléments que j'avais ce jour-là ma
connaissance et vous les avez rappelé ou
madame la Présidente donc voilà donc je
vous ai dit en toute transparence ce que
j'avais comme élément je suis encore une
fois une experte et c'est aussi pour ça
que Monsieur Charo aujourd'hui là pour
m'accompagner je vous ai dit aussi que
nos grands principes dans la stratégie
industrielle c'est de réfléchir de
d'essayer d'anticiper on n'est pas
toujours parfait on essaye d'anticiper
ses besoins industriels ce qui fait
qu'il y a des projets qui sont
indifférentes il y a des projets qui
sont déjà bien approfondis évalués qu'on
toutes les datages on va dire pour
supporter des décisions et puis il y a
des projets qui sont plus de en cours
d'évolution donc c'est un gros groupe 20
000 personnes je vous ai dit 16 sites en
France donc je n'ai pas forcément à un
moment donné tous les éléments de
détails donc je vous ai dit ce jour là
que je n'étais pas forcément j'avais pas
dans mes mains tous les éléments donc en
tout cas j'espère qu'on peut apporter
plus d'éléments sur aujourd'hui le
rationnel je vais essayer juste de
compléter par rapport à ce qui a été dit
ces sites on a besoin de les transformer
c'est à dire que quand on vous dit le
jour de l'audition dernière on veut
investir ces 60 millions parce qu'on a
besoin et on croit en la chimie de
demain en revanche la chimie de Marne
cette expliquée n'est absolument pas la
chimie d'hier donc je sais que c'est
difficile et je vais venir sur votre
deuxième question sur les personnes et
nos collaborateurs c'est évidemment une
remise en question de nos façons de
travailler et de nos outils et je viens
sur votre deuxième question parce que
elle me tient à cœur et je fais la
visite des sites de depuis que j'ai
rejoint le groupe et je vois des
collaborateurs engagés et je me suis
dans les propos introductifs je me suis
permis de rappeler encore une fois les
efforts de nos collaborateurs pour
améliorer aussi les puissances de nos
outils industriels je me permets juste
de de
pas de corriger mais de sur le point on
ne parle pas de licenciement on ne parle
pas de départ contraint nous ce qu'on
nous travaillons avec les collaborateurs
par rapport à ces nouveaux besoins c'est
dans le cas de ce qu'on appelle la GPP
donc c'est des départs en fait où on
accompagne des collaborateurs à la fois
c'est pas toujours des départs parce que
c'est de la mobilité interne aussi donc
on regarde nos métiers sensibles nos
métiers en tension et on les accompagne
donc on a effectivement sur ces deux
sites là identifier 135 postes qui
pourraient être amenés effectivement à
être impacté dans ce projet ce n'est
absolument pas des départs contraints il
y a zéro départ contraint on a du temps
je pense que Monsieur Charola elle
rappelait c'est des projets qui vont
jusqu'à 2025 26 donc on va accompagner
les collaborateurs et c'est donc tout le
dialogue qui est fait au niveau des
équipes industrielles avec les managers
les équipes sur place
il y a quand même les 60 millions qui
ont été un mois quand je relis et avec
les précautions que j'ai prises
effectivement ou vous madame et Madame
Jolivet aussi vous avez pris la
précaution dire nous allons vérifier nos
informations que nous vous donnons donc
il y a pas de souci là-dessus mais sur
les informations à ce moment-là c'est
que il est quand même dit c'est unité de
lancement c'est 60 millions d'euros sur
plusieurs années c'est un site qui a
bénéficié d'investissement notamment
cette unité de lancement donc ça veut
dire qui a bénéficié donc c'est ça qui
me c'est à dire que si cette unité à
bénéficier de 60 millions d'euros elle
est pour moi elle n'est pas obsolète il
peut y avoir des améliorations etc
première question deuxième question vous
dites oui mais c'est pas vraiment des
licenciements ok j'écoute mais j'entends
j'écoute et j'entends mais ça veut dire
même que d'après toujours les
informations ça veut dire quand même 50
tonnes de principes actifs en moins
est-ce que ça c'est avéré ou pas alors
qu'on est au cœur de notre de notre
commission d'enquête qui est la pénurie
donc vous comprendrez bien que pour nous
50 tonnes de principes actifs ça n'est
pas anodin le intervenir sur
seconde pour faire vivre et animer cette
commission des collègues veulent
intervenir bien sûr donc peut-être
peut-être je n'ai pas été très clair en
fait sur le sur la plateforme chimie
donc les trois sites de sisterons
aramont et Mourenx on a 14 bâtiments de
production
dans ces 14 bâtiments de production est
inclus le fameux bâtiment
ulpv qui a été mentionné à plusieurs
reprises ou LPV étant l'acronyme de
unité de lancement petit volume donc
c'est le bâtiment qui a fait l'objet des
60 millions d'euros d'investissement qui
ont été mentionnés qui bien sûr tout
neuf et que et qu'on va utiliser dans
les dans la décennie et plus tard qui
vient évidemment le bâtiment les deux
bâtiments qui vont être arrêtés l'un
assisteront l'eau traite Aramon sont des
bâtiments très anciens comme je l'ai
expliqué là 100 ans assisteront l'autre
à plus de 50 ans à Ramon des bâtiments
qui sont obsolètes qui sont entièrement
manuels et qui ne sont plus du tout
adaptés à la chimie la chimie de demain
la chimie de masse est une chimie
différente à la fois parce que les
molécules à fabriquer sont beaucoup plus
complexes donc d'une structure chimie
beaucoup plus complexe donc vont
nécessiter un nombre d'étapes de
synthèse beaucoup plus grand que par le
passé donc on va commencer par des
volumes relativement importants et puis
au fur et à mesure ceux de la synthèse
on a des volumes plus petits d'où
d'ailleurs le design de lieu de PV c'est
le premier point la chimie de demain
elle est aussi partiellement en continu
donc en fait les méthodes de synthèse
aujourd'hui sont soit ce qu'on appelle
du batch donc en fait c'est un peu de la
cuisine dans une casserole vous mélangez
les différents produits et vous et vous
isolez votre votre principal actif soit
on continue qui est déjà utilisé dans le
dans la pétrochimie par exemple dans des
dans des grands volumes et qui
maintenant peut être utilisé dans la
chimie film pharmaceutique donc c'est
aussi un changement de technologie alors
qui sera pas qui sera pas pour toutes
les synthèses ce sera pas pour tous les
produits mais c'est aussi un changement
technologique et au-delà des fameux 60
millions là qui qui font débat on a
prévu d'investir significativement dans
cette technologie j'ai noté je vous ai
mentionné tout à l'heure 20 millions
d'euros d'investissement qui sont prévus
donc ils vont venir dans les années à
venir et l'ulpv d'ailleurs a été conçu
de façon à pouvoir être étendu pour
implémenter ces nouvelles technologies
donc j'espère que je suis clair au
niveau des quelque part du basculement
technologique dont on parle entre un
bâtiment totalement obsolète et
entièrement manuel qui a 100 ans et puis
une unité flambant neuve qui est dédiée
à une chimie sur des technologies
nouvelles de chimie pour les nouveaux
produits
de réponse qui vous préoccupait avant
cette audition on a bien entendu ce qui
a dit madame de le voir c'est à dire
qu'elle n'était pas au courant le 12
avril de ce qu'elle est annoncé le 13
avec la personne qui avait rédigé la
fiche ne l'était pas non plus
il n'y avait pas il n'y a pas eu
d'informations contradictoires ou
erronées devant cette table je vous ai
répondu avec mon niveau de connaissance
on peut revisionner les images vous me
verrez chercher dans les documents
sur les principes actifs excusez-moi je
suis pas sûr qu'on a répondu sur votre
question des principes actifs il nous
reste 19 minutes
si je puis me permettre raisonner en
tonnes de principes actifs ça ne veut
pas vraiment dire grand-chose parce que
ça dépend vraiment du
50 tonnes ça fait quelques boîtes mais
ça dépend du type de produits dont on
parle donc si vous voulez ce qui peut
être intéressant c'est de regarder en
nombre de produits donc en fait sur la
plateforme chimie on produit à peu près
45 produits 45 pardon principal actif
sur les trois sites que je citer il y a
pour donner un ordre de grandeur il y a
7 principes actifs dont les
présentations finales donc seulement la
boîte sont vendues à plus d'un million
d'unités en France il y a trois
principes actifs sur les 45 dans les
présentations sont vendues à plus de 100
millions d'unités donc 100 millions de
boîtes à plus de 100 millions de boîtes
dans le monde donc ça vous donne un
petit peu les ordres de grandeur comme
l'a dit Madame d'un Volvo ce qu'on va
faire c'est on concentre avec ce projet
nos activités on recentre on va dire
avec ce projet nos activités sur les
principes actifs qui sont soit des
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur soit les essentielles médecine de
la classification
OMS et on investit à la fois pour
supporter la croissance d'un certain
nombre de produits majeurs existants
déjà donc qui sont des produits grand
volumes et comme je vous expliquer pour
le lancement des nouveaux produits donc
dans le même temps et c'est ce qui a
motivé justement l'arrêt des deux
bâtiments assisteront et aramont
parmi les 45 principes actifs on va
arrêter 13 principes actifs dont 7 sont
commercialisées en France aujourd'hui et
les 7 principes actifs qui sont
commercialisés en France seront
transférés à un tiers donc on va pas
arrêter de produire on va simplement
transférer le produit fini on va dire à
un tiers la plupart d'ailleurs des
français ou européen tout à fait donc
ces produits et
lorsqu'on lorsqu'il y a cette ce
mécanisme de cession Sanofi s'engage
bien sûr à produire pour le tir en
question pendant un certain nombre
d'années parce qu'il y a aussi un
problème de transfert réglementaire afin
de mise à jour réglementaire à faire
sachant que pour la plupart de ces
produits enfin pour pas dire tous ces
produits en fait ils sont disponibles
sur le marché déjà mais néanmoins Sanofi
continue de produire au moins trois ans
si ce n'est parfois 5 ans se
contractuellement avec le tiers qui
reprend donc l'activité ne s'arrête pas
tout de suite et c'est pour ça que je
mette à l'horizon de temps à l'horizon
2026 ou même 2027 le temps que ces
transferts aient lieu donc voilà avec un
élément sur on va dire l'ancienneté je
sais pas si on dit comme ça mais des AMM
en fait sur des API puisqu'en moyenne
ils ont 50 ans donc quand je vous le
disais le premier grand principe de
notre transformation industrielle c'est
de s'adapter aux besoins aussi
l'innovation est tant mieux en
innovation en sciences fait que on a
besoin de certaines molécules et dans le
temps certaines finalement diminuent
aussi donc il y a une ancienneté aussi
sur sur les mêmes de ses aps je pense
qu'il a d'autres questions
merci monsieur le président
je vais continuer alors d'abord
une question générale vous avez évoqué
madame la Présidente tout à l'heure la
part du marché français dans le chiffre
d'affaires de Sanofi si j'ai bien
compris 4%
quelle est la part du marché européen
dans votre chiffre d'affaires total et
est-ce qu'il y a des freins pour que le
chiffre d'affaires que représente le
marché français augmente ou pas
puisque on est bien là on est dans une
commission d'enquête sur les pénuries de
médicaments et pour avoir des réponses
et on dit il faut réindustrialiser or
vous êtes déjà présent sur le territoire
français pour la logique c'est pour
avoir une forme c'est pas garantie
évidemment mais de souveraineté
sanitaire bon et là on voit que vous
êtes un acteur important du monde de la
pharmacie du médicament et que 96% de
votre chiffre d'affaires se fait à
l'extérieur du marché français donc
j'aimerais comprendre s'il y a des
freins pour que le marché français
prenne plus une part plus importante ou
pas est-ce que c'est un choix délibéré
ou pas parce que il y a un seuil ou pas
ensuite je reviens au
principe actif que vous allez arrêter
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner la
liste des 7 principes actifs
commercialisés sur le marché français
que vous allez arrêter est-ce que vous
fabriquez la prednisone
si oui ou pas et sinon à qui vous
l'achetez et est-ce qu'à un moment donné
on pourra en retrouver dans les
pharmacies de France et de Navarre et
est-ce que médicament antileptique que
vous connaissez bien qui s'appelle le
Sabril qui suscite les mois des patients
qui sont sous traitement pour lequel il
y a une procédure qui a été mise en
place pour paquet de rupture de
traitement etc
j'ai vu la fiche que qui permet aux
pharmaciens j'ai vu que le marché
hospitalier était fourni était les
pharmaciens pouvaient
recevoir la boîte pour un patient donné
pour autant pas de nouveau traitement
initié quelle est votre stock de réserve
parce que ça fait déjà je crois que la
tension l'approvisionnement date du mois
de janvier
j'ai vu aussi j'ai lu que vous étiez pas
en mesure en tout cas le laboratoire ne
s'avançait pas sur un retour à la
normale concernant cette molécule est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
aujourd'hui voilà et j'avoue que
je suis à la je comprends le besoin
j'allais dire d'être avec son temps et
de pouvoir mettre en place des nouvelles
technologies avec la chimie de du 21e
siècle pour autant j'ai entendu aussi
qu'en fonction de l'ancienneté et c'est
la question des médicaments mature
que vous allez délibérément arrêter donc
quels sont les acteurs du marché
français
c'est en tout cas ce que j'ai cru
comprendre peut-être que je me suis
trompé j'ai bien compris que vous alliez
les fabriquer pendant trois ans et
transmettre mais en attendant
d'abord quels sont je vous ai posé la
question quels sont ces principes actifs
et
et vraiment est-ce que avant de prendre
ces décisions là qui sont un choix qui
s'entend en matière d'innovation
pourquoi vous n'arrivez pas à le dire à
tenir les deux se faire à la fois les
sur l'innovation et à la fois continuer
à fabriquer des médicaments matures
je me permets de commencer et puis
monsieur Charo complète je prends juste
le sujet ça brille pour commencer déjà
voilà je suis maman aussi donc je
comprends déjà la situation c'est
difficile parce que en l'occurrence
c'est parti d'une situation avec une
maman qui trouvait pas le traitement
pour pour son enfant et je comprends
franchement le besoin
on se rend compte c'est qu'il faudra il
faut sûrement en fait qu'on revoit le
process alors bien évidemment tout ça se
fait pas que le laboratoire le
contingentement il est fait avec la NSM
donc c'est pas nous qui prenons la
décision c'est qu'en fait le médicament
on a un certain niveau de stock on voit
que le stock diminue on discute avec le
process qui avait été rappelé par
Monsieur Jean-Marc Lacroix la dernière
fois donc je reviens pas sur le détail
donc une fois que le process a été mis
en place on se rend compte qu'ils ne
fonctionne pas très bien et je jette la
pierre à personne c'est l'information
pharmacien c'est comment le pharmacien
lui va parce qu'en l'occurrence ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a du
stock je l'avais dit les hôpitaux ont
accès mais aussi les pharmacies de ville
il faut qu'il contactent le laboratoire
sous 48 heures le laboratoire fourni on
a été en mesure pour tous les laborats
les pharmaciens pardon qui nous ont
contacté 100% des demandes ont été
faites et ils ont été livrés en revanche
il y a améliorer on l'a noté sûrement la
communication avec le pharmacien moi je
serais ravie de d'aller plus loin avec
les syndicats de pharmaciens voir
comment on peut les aider à faire cette
en tout cas cette information patient
parce qu'il y a je pense une défaillance
à ce niveau là et chaque patient et en
mesure de savoir en tout cas plus c'est
mon opinion personnelle on met encore
une fois il y a un process en place les
pharmaciens peuvent contacter
laboratoire sous 48 heures ils sont
livrés juste sur la partie Sabri
ça répond à votre question pas Madame
pas vraiment en fait ça je me semble
avoir dit dans le j'ai peut-être pas été
clair mais c'était ces tensions qui
datent et vous l'avez dit il y a un
problème de process de process de
fabrication
est-ce que vous avez de la visibilité
sur un retour à la normale sur ce
médicament là particulièrement et puis
il y a la question sur la prednisone si
vous pardon désolé une partie de votre
question
sur la partie visibilité donc oui c'est
un sujet qui date de plusieurs mois
il est palier que à nous on avait
expliqué dans la chaîne de production là
typiquement ça nos partenaires qui est
en situation de difficulté donc le temps
que ça revienne il y a plusieurs choses
qui peuvent être faites un chercher un
alternatif donc un autre partenaire
c'est ce qu'on a mis en place mais ça se
fait pas du jour au lendemain donc on
cherche un autre partenaire qui peut
nous aider à mettre ce médicament pour
le coup sur le marché mais on a expliqué
tout le process industriel tout est bien
que c'est pas quelque chose qui se fait
en quelques semaines donc on a mis un
processus alternatif et on pense que
d'ici quelques mois donc je parle
malheureusement c'est pas quelques
semaines c'est quelques mois je veux pas
vous dire quelque chose qui est faux
j'ai pas une date exacte mais on évalue
à quelques mois et d'ici là on continue
ce contingentement et on a cette
discussion avec la NSM
je prends les autres questions
je voulais répondre à votre question sur
la liste des produits qui vont être qui
vont être transférés enfin les investis
un tiers dans les dans les trois ans qui
viennent en fait donc il y a le
chlorazépate qui est le principe actif
du Tranxen il y a le flashépates qui les
principes actif du Victor la cyclopédine
qui le principe actif de tiklid la
chlorpromazine qui est le principe actif
de Largactil pardon
la trinyprabine qui est le principe
actif de surmontil et puis un dernier
que je peux pas mentionner ici pour des
raisons de confidentialité parce que la
transaction n'est pas terminée avec le
partenaire voilà et donc mais tous ces
tous ces tous ces produits encore une
fois ne vont pas disparaître du marché
ils sont transférés à laboratoire
français ou européen pour lequel encore
une fois on va qu'on va continuer de
produire entre 3 entre 3 et 5
alors c'est ça dépend des ça dépend des
des contrats on va dire entre 3 entre 3
et 5 ans en général en général trois ans
sur parce que de toute façon c'est le
temps quelque part de mise à jour des
dossiers réglementaires et des
changements liés à la supraction
et en général tous ces contrats ont une
clause d'extension d'un an ou de deux
ans donc trois ans sur ferme après ça
peut ça peut aller au-delà selon si le
partenaire va le laboratoire à qui on a
cédé ce produit à un problème de
fourniture ou pas si jamais il a un
problème on va continuer de fonder bien
sûr
j'ai oublié décidément de répondre à une
autre partie de votre question madame
sur le chiffre d'affaires européen donc
c'est à peu près 4 fois en proportion
vous avez les informations plus précis
je pense qu'on était transmises sur le
questionnaire c'est à peu près quatre
fois savoir que sur le chiffre
d'affaires il y a deux composantes en
fait qui rentrent en compte il y a les
volumes et la valeur et on a beaucoup
discuté dans différents
et cette je pense que vous l'avez
beaucoup entendu le prix pas forcément
avec les prix les plus bas d'Europe
quasiment on a souvent en valeur on est
inférieur aux autres pays européens en
volume en revanche on peut être
au-dessus donc
en tout cas nous on est l'équipe France
donc on pousse à ce que la France soit
on va dire le plus fort au niveau de
l'Europe maintenant tout n'est pas
finalement sur la valeur on n'est pas
les seuls décisionnaires de cet impact
sur le chiffre d'affaires
donc le principe actif de la prévision
n'est pas fabriqué par par Sanofi il est
acheté il est acheté un tiers
là je peux pas vous répondre je vérifie
comment
donc là je peux il faut que je vérifie
[Musique]
merci beaucoup je serai rapide juste
pour être sûr que sur l'histoire des 50
tonnes etc on a bien compris
l'impact que ça va avoir j'entends le
fait que le poids bon c'est peut-être
pas l'unité de mesure la plus pertinente
en termes de
d'accessibilité disponibilité des
médicaments donc juste une question
simple est-ce que vous pouvez nous
garantir que les décisions que vous avez
prises ne peuvent pas engendrer de
pénurie de médicaments
voilà la deuxième question c'est lié un
des
un des des une des choses qui peuvent
créer une difficulté d'accès aux
médicaments c'est évidemment la
disponibilité matérielle est-ce qu'on
arrive à les produire c'est aussi la
question du prix et je voulais savoir si
vous pouviez nous dire
dans
donc quand vous
négociez vos prix je vous demande pas
d'informations que vous pouvez pas me
communiquer à cause du secret d'affaires
et tout ça mais en gros quand vous
déterminez vos coûts de développement et
vos prix de revient
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire en
moyenne dans le coût de développement
quel poids à ont les dépenses en
communication marketing relation
publique etc quand vous déterminez ce
que c'est le coût pour vous la
production d'un médicament puisqu'on
sait que dans le coup de production de
médicaments mais pas que le coût des
machines et des salaires etc on met
aussi parfois le coût de la pub la
communication est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire ce que ça représente en
moyenne je vous demande pas sur un
médicament particulier voilà et aussi
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire si donc
vous avez vous avez dit que vous aviez
une une structure
avec multiples branches et active au
niveau international
il y a une pratique parfois qui en tout
cas qui nous est relaté par par la
presse ou par des ONG qui consistent à
faire
artificiellement monter le prix
le coût de production d'un médicament en
achetant à l'intérieur d'une même
entreprise à une autre branche un
principe actif qu'on a acheté dans un
pays où il était pas très cher par
exemple acheter à votre branche principe
actif en France voilà et quand vous
pensez que le médicament va finalement
pouvoir être mis sur le marché breveté
le principe actif est acheté à une
branche qui du même groupe qu'il le vend
beaucoup plus cher ce qui fait monter
artificiellement le le coût et donc à la
fin le prix est donc à la fin le coût
pour la société est donc à la fin ça a
un impact sur l'accessibilité
et le donc et la dernière question c'est
pour revenir sur le Sabril
est-ce que aujourd'hui le les stocks
qu'on a et la méthodologie qu'on a mis
en place jusqu'à ce qu'on trouve un
nouveau process est-ce que selon vous on
peut donner accès aux médicaments à tous
les enfants qui en ont besoin jusqu'à ce
que on est un nouveau process
merci pour votre question de Emilian
merci madame la Présidente bonjour
revenir sur deux points
vous avez parlé des de l'accompagnant ça
n'est pas un licenciement sec si j'ai
bien compris mais j'aimerais bien que
vous nous précisiez quelles sont ces
mesures d'accompagnement de personnes
sont des techniciens quand un
savoir-faire et est-ce que vous pouvez
les relocaliser sur une autre production
sur le même site ou à proximité donc
quelle est cette précision quelle est
cette campagne non ensuite moi j'aurai
la même question un petit peu que
Corinne Humbert sur le fait d'arrêter
certaines productions vous avez cité
excuse-moi
vous avez cité si vous êtes produit et
je suis un peu étonné qu'on puisse pas
faire les deux j'allais dire la chimie
ancienne
et et la chimie moderne et ce d'autant
plus que on avait eu
novembre 2020 ou 21 je me suis pris
exactement maintenant une audition dans
un cadre différent dans la salle Médicis
en bas du directeur France de Sanofi et
qui nous avait clairement dit la
recherche de développement en chimie
pour Sanofi ça n'est plus intéressant on
arrête on avait parlé du site de
Strasbourg où on avait alors qu'il y
avait eu quand même 4 milliards de
dividendes de distribués à des
actionnaires où il avait eu 400
licenciements de chercheurs parce qu'il
n'était chercheur comme chimie et pas en
biotechnologie en biothérapie et en
thérapie cellulaire ou génique donc moi
ça m'interpelle quand même de savoir si
vraiment Sanofi va continuer à faire la
recherche développement en chimie
ou si vraiment la stratégie de cette
grosse boîte quand même vous avez dit 20
000 personnes soyons uniquement vers les
biothérapies thérapie génique qui sont
effectivement j'allais dire pourvoyeuse
de gain beaucoup plus important que le
doliprane le Venox ou le la réactive
en tout cas dans l'émission
d'une entreprise comme la vôtre les
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur comme ceux que vous venez de vous
citer parce que l'argotisme s'en fait
partie
sont aussi importants dans le dans votre
panier de propositions dans la mesure où
un laboratoire a aussi quelque part même
si c'est une structure privée et
financièrement importante a aussi une
mission d'intérêt public et un devoir de
pouvoir tout proposer voilà même la
présidence c'est ce qu'on s'efforce de
faire tous les jours et c'est un groupe
qui j'ai
compris
non et c'est bien pour ça qu'on a aussi
tous ces investissements sur notamment
cette unité chimie a comme la fin vient
en mangeant on peut poser une question
une question complémentaire et après
non non juste une remarque et pardon de
mon incorrection mais je montrais à ma
collègue Mélanie un mail que nous avons
reçu 17h18 pardon de le préciser je suis
pharmacien d'officine il y en a d'autres
dans la salle et nous venons recevoir un
mail disant qu'on continue ou qu'on peut
continuer effectivement à pleurer des
stocks mais surtout c'est le point 2
mais de ne pas initier de nouveaux
traitements
voilà sur le sabrill donc on est quand
même face une vraie difficulté sur le
Sabril on reçoit un mail du labo 17h18
de ne pas initier de nouveaux traitement
qu'est-ce qu'on répond face aux familles
aux parents
nous merci il y a plein de questions que
j'ai je suis désolé je sais pas ce qu'on
va pouvoir tout couvrir madame la
présente donc on pourra répondre à
d'autres questions par écrit si jamais
on n'a pas le temps mais sur cette
question là on n'est pas prescripteur
non mais nous on n'est pas le
prescripteur donc c'est
oui oui mais déjà nous laboratoire on
peut pas donner la consigne on n'a pas
le patient déjà c'est pas notre métier
moi je vous dis sur le Sabril
aujourd'hui s'il y a un besoin de
médicaments le pharmacien contacte le
laboratoire on peut reprendre ce sujet
là je suis pas au courant de je veux
bien regarder ce mail en question
des alternatives c'est pas propre enfin
dans ce type de situation vous
connaissez aussi le process c'est que
s'il y a des alternatives thérapeutiques
il est toujours recommandé de prendre
une alternative si on n'a pas là
aujourd'hui
mon message est si un pharmacien a
besoin il contacte le laboratoire et
sous 48 heures on est en mesure 100% des
demandes ont été honorées à ce jour face
à un message pour l'information des
patients je pense que c'est important je
pense qu'on parlait de la maman tout à
l'heure je pense qu'il y a d'autres
parents qui sont dans le cas c'est un
message qu'il faut enfin je pense qu'il
y a c'est un des items où on peut
collectivement s'améliorer sur
l'information des patients j'y tiens
c'est pas parfait je suis bien désolé de
ça mais je pense que l'information des
patients peut être
de questions j'espère que j'ai pas
oublié les questions en cours de route
mais bon alors peut-être c'est pas
traité dans l'ordre mais déjà pour pour
revenir sur quelque chose qui me tient à
cœur je suis chimiste de formation donc
c'était votre question concernant le les
technologies utilisées pour développer
de nouveaux médicaments oui la chimie
fait partie de la boîte à outils comme
la culture cellulaire comme la
fermentation microbienne etc donc quand
on cherche un nouveau médicament on
cherche pas à se spécialement une
technologie on cherche une cible
thérapeutique et la molécule bien sûr
donc la chimie est une une de nos à nos
outils si je puis dire dans la boîte à
outils et c'est la raison pour laquelle
Sanofi veut continuer à maîtriser cette
cette technologie tant pour les
problématures que pour les nouveaux
produits d'ailleurs si vous regardez le
pipeline de notre R&D vous constaterez
que les prochains produits en termes de
lancement dans à partir de 2024 sont
beaucoup des molécules de synthèse on a
cité le taulive au tennis tout à l'heure
il y en a d'autres ils abrutis etc qui
sont des molécules de synthèse donc oui
ça fait partie de et globalement quand
vous regardez le portefeuille de la
pharmacie mondiale on est sur un ratio
40 60 à peu près 40% de molécules de
synthèse 60% de molécules dites
biologiques enfin de grosses molécules
donc les molécules synthèse vont
perdurer dans le portefeuille de Sanofi
après il y a une question à laquelle je
tiens à répondre c'est sur est-ce que
les les sessions dont j'ai parlé un
laboratoire tiers vont engendrer des
risques de rupture on fait tout pour
qu'il n'y a pas de il n'y a pas de
risque de rupture alors bien sûr je peux
pas garantir aujourd'hui à 100% devant
cette audience qu'il n'y aura pas de
rupture mais en tout cas tout est mis en
oeuvre comme comme pour nos propres
produits pour éviter toute rupture et
d'ailleurs sur les produits que j'ai
cité aujourd'hui on n'est pas en tension
en termes d'approvisionnement donc il y
a pas un lien du tout entre les
problèmes d'approvisionnement ou de
rupture que l'on peut subir aujourd'hui
et ce plan de transformation de la
plateforme chimie puis après je voudrais
venir aussi la question sur
l'accompagnement des collaborateurs
aussi quelque chose qui me tient fort à
cœur vous savez qu'on a signé avec les
partenaires sociaux un dispositif donc
qui s'appelle la GPP qui qui va être
utilisé pleinement dans dans ce cas là
le premier point c'est que tout se fait
sur la base du volontariat
donc il y a pas deuxièmement il y a des
mesures de départ en retraite anticipés
et quand on regarde le nombre de la
pyramide des âges le nombre de
collaborateurs impactés donc 70 sur un
site trans 65 sur l'autre une grande
partie de ces collaborateurs sont
éligibles à des mesures d'âge pour ceux
qui ne seront pas on va redéployer les
ressources au sein du site il y aura pas
de mobilité contrainte en dehors en
dehors des sites on a assez de postes et
d'activités sur les sites en question
pour proposer un parcours professionnel
et certaines personnes d'ailleurs nous
ont sollicité pour dire moi c'est
l'occasion de je faisais de la
production d'aller en qualité ou d'aller
d'avoir une évolution professionnelle au
sein de leur site donc si vous voulez
d'un point de vue social il y a cette
transformation et va être gérée de façon
très facile si vous me permettez le mot
après ce qui avait d'autres questions
est-ce qu'il y a une question que j'ai
oublié dans ce que vous avez
la lecture de ce que je viens de voir
effectivement il y a un conseil de ne
pas initier de nouveaux traitements avec
le Sabri donc voilà
très bien
je va juste quand même par rapport à ce
que en fait les 7 les 7 principes que
vous abandonnez les sept principes
actifs que vous abandonnez en vous en
vous garantissant du fait que vous allez
produire pendant 3 à 5 ans pour
permettre la passation etc mais en fait
si j'ai bien compris les 7 les 7
principes actifs qui sont arrêtés font
partie enfin ce sont des ITM et la
deuxième la deuxième question c'est
est-ce qu'avec la fermeture que vous que
vous envisagez finalement vous ne vous
ne faites pas en sorte que c'est mes
collègues qui l'ont qui l'ont qui l'ont
posé donc j'insiste là dessus en fait
vous vous polarisez ou vous vous
concentrez plus exactement sur les
seules molécules innovantes au détriment
des produits non mais avec je suis je
suis pas en train de dire que vous
abandonnez écoutez
toute l'entièreté de mes propos je suis
pas en train de dire que vous vous
abandonnez tout je suis en train de dire
que par rapport au fait que vous
l'équilibre parce que là vous en
abandonnez 7 et puisque j'ai bien
compris qu'à chaque fois vous avez une
adaptabilité qui peut être positive les
choses risquent de se poursuivre
peut-être que dans un an si on se revoit
ce nouveau set où etc est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas sur une logique en fait et
c'est ce que ce qu'a dit ma collègue
Corinne Imbert en disant que c'est quand
même et aussi Émilienne c'est quand même
beaucoup plus
lucratif pour le dire de manière très
directe de se consacrer aux molécules
innovantes plutôt que au produit mature
voilà c'est c'est vraiment là-dessus
notre souci parce que parce que les
pénuries ne touchent pas les les
produits innovants principalement je dis
pas que ça ne touche pas mais sur la
quantité ce sont les médicaments les
médicaments matures
je pense qu'on a plusieurs sénateurs et
sénatrices qui peuvent en témoigner
directement
dans le cas spécifique de la plateforme
chimie là qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
je m'inscris un petit peu en fou à ce
que vous avez dit parce que lorsqu'on
regarde l'activité des sites aujourd'hui
et dans le futur une très grosse partie
de leur activité reste sur les produits
matures
je vous l'ai dit on fait 45 principes
actifs sur ces sites donc une grande pas
la très grande majorité de ces principes
actifs vont demeurer et quand on regarde
encore une fois le ratio d'activité qui
est dédié pour l'un au nouveau produit
donc aux produits innovants et l'autre
produit mature le ratio c'est peut-être
80 20 ou 80 enfin
on reste principalement sur sur nos
sites de chimie sur des activités de
liées au portefeuille de produits nature
si je puis me permettre il y a quand
même deux points je voudrais quand même
si vous me le permettez deux points je
voudrais assister parce que ça fait quoi
un petit peu à votre question vous
parliez de des problèmes de rupture il
faut savoir quand même que le problème
de pénurie d'abord il est imputable à
Sanofi d'environ 30 % des cas en 70 %
des cas c'est un problème de rupture
chez nos fournisseurs c'est un problème
de transport c'est un problème de
fiabilité de prévision dans certains cas
avec des survente ou des ou des
sous-ventes et l'année dernière a été
une année très difficile pour l'ensemble
de l'industrie d'ailleurs pas que
pharmaceutique mais en particulier
pharmaceutique avec pendant le covid on
a quelque part consommé une partie des
stocks mondiaux et puis après on a eu la
guerre et une demande également très
forte en termes de transport donc ceci
je sais pas en train de chercher des
excuses du tout mais pour vous dire que
le contexte de 2022 était quand même
très très particulier pour lutter contre
ça on a toute une stratégie quand même
de plusieurs moyens pour rendre plus
robuste notre notre chaîne
d'approvisionnement c'est bien sûr
d'avoir des un système de sites ou de
ligne backup donc savoir alors quand je
dis backup ça peut être interne sur le
même site ça peut être interne sur
Sanofi sur deux sites ou internes et
puis externe on a toutes les options et
pour nos produits majeurs c'est ce qu'on
essaie de développer alors on peut
jamais être avoir un backup à 100 % il
n'existe on peut pas dupliquer une
capacité mais au moins pour une partie
de la production de partie des volumes
d'avoir un système de backup c'est aussi
le stock évidemment qui est une façon de
gérer c'est aussi le multi-sourcing
auprès de nos fournisseurs vous savez
sans doute que l'industrie
pharmaceutique de par les contraintes
réglementaires en fait est beaucoup ce
qu'on appelle mono-sourcés donc pour une
grande partie de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement et vous savez pour
faire un médicament il faut plusieurs
centaines d'ingrédients et bien on est
sur beaucoup d'entre eux on est
monocrité certains étant des commodités
d'ailleurs pour lesquelles on a
également des difficultés
d'approvisionnement il faut aussi qu'on
s'intègre mieux que nos fournisseurs
donc faut qu'on développe multi-sourcing
donc vous voyez il y a toute une
batterie de au-delà de de ce qu'on
discutait qui est mise en place de façon
à améliorer la robustesse de notre de
votre chaîne d'approvisionnement puis
dernier point si vous le permettez je
serais très rapide il on a parlé de
l'attractivité de la France et de la
relocalisation tu as quand même souligné
que on a plusieurs produits qui étaient
fabriqués dans des pays hors de France
qui sont relocalisés dans nos usines
français je peux vous donner trois
exemples le Zénon qui fabriquait dans en
Turquie va être rapatrier sur notre site
de Tours le mucose qui était fait en
Allemagne à Cologne va être rapatrier
sur notre site d'Amélie d'ailleurs ça
c'est fait c'est quand même 10 millions
d'euros de CAPEX et puis le renvella qui
est un produit qui est un produit pour
l'insuffisance rénale chronique va être
rapatriés de Waterford à Ambares là
aussi c'est 15 millions d'euros
d'investissement donc si on maintient la
compétitivité et l'attractivité de nos
sites on sait aussi
réinternaliser ou relocaliser de la
production dans notre pays
merci Madame
merci beaucoup
de cette audition
et nous poursuivons oui c'est juste que
sur le la structure du prix et le coût
développe enfin je crois que j'ai pas
trouvé la réponse
c'est toujours la question qu'on se pose
c'est sur le prix au final affiché
quelle est la part de la part du 11
renvoie la part du façonnage la part du
marketing puisque en l'occurrence c'est
ça est tenté et c'est vrai qu'on voilà
c'est compliqué quand même de comprendre
finalement on se rend compte que la
partie chimique c'est la part la plus la
plus faible finalement du coup du
médicament
j'espère qu'on a quand même su montrer
l'engagement des collaborateurs et du
groupe sur le sol français merci pour
votre attention qu'on ne met pas en
cause ça n'est pas ça qui était mis en
cause mais vous vous voilà vous avez
raison d'insister mais vous avez aussi
compris que nous sommes dans une sur une
commission d'enquête et qu'il est tout à
fait important pour nous d'ailleurs
comme pour vous d'avoir vraiment la
réalité des choses et le fait que vous
ayez eu l'occasion de détailler
d'explicité des propos qui n'étaient pas
finalement exactes et j'ai bien donné
les tenants et les aboutissants de ces
imperfections on va dire on fait que
c'est clair pour tout le monde donc et
pour vous et pour nous voilà j'ai
remercie de nous avoir donné
l'opportunité de revenir et d'expliquer
notre stratégie merci beaucoup au revoir
merci
mes chers collègues nous poursuivons les
travaux de notre commission d'enquête
par l'audition du Professeur Alain
Fischer que je remercie de cette
mobilisé aujourd'hui
si nous vous connaissons tout en tous en
tant que président du Conseil
d'orientation de la stratégie vaccinale
au plus fort de la pandémie de la
covid-19 nous avons eu l'occasion de
vous avoir plusieurs fois en édition
c'est le président le président de
l'Académie des Sciences et professeurs
honoraires du Collège de France
spécialiste en immunologie pédiatrique
que nous entendons aujourd'hui
j'ajoute que vous êtes l'auteur au nom
de la Fondation Terra Nova d'un rapport
rendu public le 18 janvier dernier sur
la recherche médicale en France et par
ailleurs chroniqueur Aliexpress
notre commission d'enquête a un double
objet les pénuries de médicaments mais
également les choix de l'industrie
pharmaceutique française les deux étant
liés et vous avez bien compris que le
débat entre médicament mature et
innovation était très intriqués
ces deux enjeux nous ont naturellement
conduit examiné le modèle économique de
l'industrie du médicament et en
particulier la place qui occupe
l'innovation sont financement et la
prise en charge des thérapies de plus en
plus coûteuse qui en sont issues c'est à
ce titre monsieur le Président que nous
souhaitons disposer de votre expertise
en effet vous aviez alerté sur le
caractère exorbitant du prix demandé par
les laboratoires pour les médicaments
relevant des thérapies cellulaires
tissulaires cellulaire et génétique
avant la prise de conscience générale de
cette problématique dès 2020 vous aviez
démontré que l'argument mise en avant
par les laboratoires des vies
transformés par les traitements
administrés en une seule fois au prix
sans commune mesure avec ce pratiquée
jusqu'à là ne tenait pas ne serait-ce
que compte tenu du manque de recul sur
l'efficacité de ces traitements qui ne
dépassent pas trois à cinq
vous appeliez alors je cite à une vision
plus équilibrée de l'intérêt général et
d'un retour raisonnable sur
investissement qui permettent la
poursuite de l'innovation vous pourrez
nous préciser ce que vous entendez par
cette déclaration que les dernières
années n'ont fait que confirmer en
matière d'innovation vous avez également
alerté sur l'état selon vous préoccupant
de la recherche française nous serons
attentifs à vos préconisations pour
remédier à cette situation d'autant plus
préjudiciable que comme vous avez eu
l'occasion de le dire l'innovation
nécessitant en amont une recherche
active et efficace faute de quoi la
France risque d'encourager la production
de biomédicaments sont disposés de la
capacité à inventer les médicaments de
demain enfin pour en revenir aux
pénuries de médicaments proprement dites
je soulignerai que dès septembre 2022
vous alertiez sur le risque d'une
épidémie de grippe en France
concomitante avec un rebond de
l'épidémie de covid-19 l'histoire vous a
malheureusement donné raison et
l'épidémie de bronchiolite que j'allais
ajouter dans mon propos n'a fait
qu'accent UER l'impact sanitaire de
cette situation à l'origine de pénurie
qui ont d'autant plus inquiétée
l'ensemble des Français quel toucher des
produits d'usage courant comme
l'amoxicilline ou le paracétamol
nous serons
par conséquent attentif à ce que vous
pourrez nous dire sur la promotion de la
politique de santé publique que vous
appelez de vos vœux notamment s'agissant
de la prévention sur l'ensemble de ces
sujets monsieur présent je vais vous
céder la parole pour un bref propos un
productif puis madame Laurence Cohen
rapporteur de notre commission d'enquête
vous posera une première série de
questions je précise également que cette
audition est diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un compte rendu publié avant
de vous donner la parole je vous
rappelle qu'un faux témoignage est
vraiment notre commission d'enquête et
passive des peines prévues aux articles
quatre en tant que 13 434-14 et 434-15
du code pénal je vous invite à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant que je le jure je vous remercie
par ailleurs de nous faire part de vos
éventuels liens d'intérêt monsieur
Fischer
je le jure mais peut-être qu'il faut
juste de quoi qu'est-ce que je jure
toute la vérité
c'est bon
de votre invitation je tiens à préciser
à vous avez mis ce qui est exact je suis
aujourd'hui Président lacrimination je
ne parle pas au nom de l'Académie des
Sciences le palatide personnelle j'en
sais important de même si l'Académie des
sciences comme d'autres académies
évidemment s'intéressent à ces questions
en termes de liens conflit d'intérêt
j'ai pas j'ai dans si vous regardez mes
dpi qui est public et j'ai été impliqué
dans la création d'une startup mais sans
intérêt personnel et qui émane de
l'Institut je travaille encore même si
je suis censé être retraité s'appelle
institut imagine qui est sur le site de
l'hôpital Necker enfant malade et voilà
quoi en terme privé c'est tout
sur l'aspect de la pénurie médicaments
je n'ai guère de compétences dans ce
domaine donc j'en parlerai pas même si
je suis conscient qu'il y a un lien
d'ailleurs vous avez vous aviez évoqué
la question à l'instant avec les
personnes de Sanofi je me sens un peu
plus compétent sur la problématique de
l'accessibilité des médicaments
innovants et puis on peut à partir de là
selon vos souhaits continuer sur les
aspects recherche santé publique que
vous avez évoqué il y a un instant donc
pour pas être trop long vous le savez je
pense que vous l'avez entendu
multiplement il faut commencer par les
bonnes nouvelles les bonnes nouvelles
c'est qu'il depuis un certain nombre
d'années on observe et ça ne se dément
pas des avancées la recherche médicale
qui sont très significatives en termes
de thérapeutique que ce soit
thérapeutique classique du médicament
chimiques que ce soit des biothérapies
qui représente aujourd'hui 40% des
médicaments mis sur le marché ou des
thérapies cellulaires et surtout
géniques deux trois exemples pour
illustrer mon propos pour les
médicaments je vais prendre l'exemple de
la mucoviscidose donc une maladie rare
mais pas si rare que ça comme ça je
crois 6000 malades en France il y a
aujourd'hui une trithérapie
médicamenteuse qui qui est vraiment très
intéressantes pas efficace chez 100% des
malades mais la grande majorité de ces
patients et qui est doit être pris à vie
et je reviendrai ensuite évidemment sur
l'accessibilité biothérapie de multiples
bibliothérapies qui ont montré un
certain degré d'efficacité c'est pas
parfait mais pour un certain nombre de
cancers il y a eu des progrès très très
significatifs là vraiment de c'est toute
dernière année dans le traitement des
hémophilie qui sont vraiment
impressionnants dans le traitement de
maladies inflammatoire de maladies
auto-immune beaucoup d'anticorps
monoclonaux mais pas que d'autres
produits biologiques
thérapie génique il y a les fameuses
cartiselles qui aujourd'hui je crois a
été à peu près administré à 20 000
patients dans le monde ça commence à
faire il y a plusieurs déficitines
maladies génétiques diverses déficit
immunitaire hémophilie à nouveau maladie
de l'hémoglobine dans des pas tout à
fait rares comme la drépanocytose
n'était à la semi à myotrophie spinale
enfin ouais je pourrais continuer comme
ça donc ça ce sont les bonnes nouvelles
c'est qu'il y a vraiment de la vraie
avancée médicale sont pas des
médicaments MiTo sont des médicaments
transformant j'y reviendrai et puis il y
a beaucoup de perspectives les
recherches en cours dans tous ces
domaines sont florissantes
même s'il est toujours très difficile de
faire des prédictions mais il est on ne
peut pas imaginer une seconde que ce que
les avancées ne s'arrêtent en subitement
s'arrêter en 2023 je pense que les
années qui vont venir verront mis sur le
marché au moins dans certains domaines
il reste des creux terribles comme les
maladies du cerveau ou malheureusement
on est nettement moins avancé mais les
psychiatriques et d'autres enfin bref
mais enfin globalement il y a notamment
le cancer mais pas que des progrès très
significat donc ça ce sont les bonnes
nouvelles mais moins bonnes nouvelles
c'est le prix de ces médicaments si je
reprends les exemples que je vais citer
il y a un instant la mucoviscidose donc
cette trithérapie autant qu'on puisse le
savoir ce qu'on y reviendra mais comme
vous savez les prix ne sont pas connus
publiquement en France mais enfin on
peut quand même avoir un certain nombre
d'informations mais le traitement par an
pour un malade la mucovisc c'est 200000
euros et c'est à vie c'est pas une fois
c'est pas comme une thérapie génique
éventuellement les différents
traitements par Anticor monoclonaux dans
les cancers et autres
monoclonaute du cancer les ce qu'on
appelle les check point inhibiteurs qui
sont beaucoup utilisés aujourd'hui c'est
lors de 50 000 à 100000 € par curé par
malade pour les maladies communes c'est
plus seulement entre guillemets 10
20.000 euros les traits les nouveaux
traitements de l'hémophilie sont autour
de 100000 euros par an et par malade les
traitements les thérapies géniques les
fameuses quartissaient 400 000 euros par
malade
qui viennent s'ajouter à d'autres
traitements à ces les malades qui
reçoivent des quartiers Celtes s'ils ont
souvent une grève de moelle osseuse
après etc etc etc les nouveaux
traitements de l'hémophilie ont été
commercialisés aux États-Unis au prix de
3 millions de dollars par malades la
myotophie spinale est vendue le produit
est vendu en France je crois que ce
chiffre est exact encore une fois il
peut y avoir comme il y a les rabais
c'est pas tout mais je pense que le
chiffre est exact parce que je l'ai de
l'Assistance publique 1,9 millions
d'euros bon je pourrais continuer je
vais pas faire une longue liste mais
enfin voilà donc ces produits coûte
extrêmement cher ce sont les produits
les plus chers aujourd'hui de tous les
médicaments et de loin et donc
ces prix sont aujourd'hui totalement
déconnectés
mais c'est revendiqué par l'industrie je
vais revenir des coûts de Recherche
Développement production marketing c'est
déconnecté totalement déconnecté pour
alors la justification de la déconnexion
c'est de dire que ces médicaments sont
sophistiqués
leur coûts développement coûte plus cher
que ce que le médicament ou autre ça
peut être vrai mais c'est pas dans une
dimension fantastiquement plus élevée et
surtout parce que ces traitements sont
pour ceux qui sont one shot une seule
fois pourraient être on passe d'une
maladie chronique grave voire mortelle à
une maladie guéri et donc c'est
évidemment un argument qui compte qu'il
faut prendre en compte c'est la valeur
transformative si le mot est correct
transformatif de ces traitements alors
c'est pas toujours le cas on va revenir
mais enfin ce sont les arguments mis en
avant par l'industrie pharmaceutique par
spécialement française c'est évidemment
totalement mondial si on prend ces
arguments il y a aussi le que souvent
sont des maladies rares à petits marchés
si on reprend ses dons qui peuvent
nécessiter des coûts plus élevés des
prix plus élevés
concernant le l'aspect sophistiqué plus
élevé développement oui mais en fait la
quasi-totalité de ces médicaments ont
été en fait développés par la recherche
académique ou fortement proche de la
recherche académique par exemple
l'association de parents on peut penser
à l'AFM pour la myotofie spinale et
qu'ensuite c'est produire ont été
rachetés par l'industrie mais à des
coûts
ou par les revenus qui peuvent qui
reviennent à mon académique ou
associatif qui sont très loin de des
prix on peut évoquer des chiffres si
vous le souhaitez
le fait que les marchés petite taille
des marchés c'est parfois vrai pas
toujours il y a aucune corrélation entre
la taille du marché le prix des
médicaments si on regarde en détail pour
ces médicaments surtout le point
essentiel donc c'est le caractère
transformatif ou non de ces traitements
donc encore une fois certains sont
transformatifs mais sont avis si je
prends l'exemple de la mucoviscidose ou
certains traitements de l'hémophilie que
sur le temps même pour ceux qui sont
vraiment transformatifs a priorité
rapide génique on a des rares recul un
peu plus important maintenant on est à 7
8 10 ans pour certaines maladies dont
quelques cas il y a des chances que ce
soit définitif mais c'est pas sûr que ce
soit définitif dans tous les cas loin de
là et que par ailleurs notamment pour
les maladies neuromusculaires la cure
peut être incomplète qui persiste des
manifestations cliniques voire on peut
imaginer même l'apparition de
manifestations clinique n'était pas
connue mais qui apparaissent parce que
les malades survivent donc imaginez que
c'est que ce soit totalement
transformatif et qu'on s'en sort une
personne avec une maladie grave Issime
en une personne qui a une vie normale ça
peut être vrai dans quelques cas mais
c'est pas la majorité et puis il y a des
incertitudes sur le long terme
évidemment pour tous ces patients et
j'ajouterai peut-être pour moi le point
le plus important même si l'argumentaire
de l'industrie était totalement juifs il
est pas totalement faux il faut le
prendre en compte mais si les imaginons
qu'il soit totalement justes et qui
permettent pour un certain nombre de
situations moi d'abord avoir évidemment
des gains de vie et de qualité de vie ce
qui est
très important et même faire gagner de
temps en temps de l'argent parce que un
traitement one shot va coûter moins cher
qu'un traitement à vie si on prend de
l'hémophilie replanocytose encore qu'il
y a une étude qui vient de sortir aux
États-Unis qui montre que c'est pas si
évident pour la Dripper aussitôt mais au
moins pour l'hémophilie c'est à peu près
juste donc il y a un gain indéniable
mais la question qui peut se poser après
chacun est libre d'y répondre est-ce que
ce gain doit aller uniquement à
l'industriel qui a fait le produit à la
société enfin quelle est l'équilibre il
me semble que la moindre des choses
c'est de considérer que le partage du
gain doit être équilibré je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il n'est pas équilibré
voilà
à vrai dire si on regarde enfin je
répète ce qui a été écrit par beaucoup
si on regarde le comment ces prix sont
fixés ils sont surtout fixés et au plus
haut possible accepter comme pas
toujours le cas mais accepté par les
autorités réglementaires quand il y en a
c'est en Europe et pas aux États-Unis
malheureusement je reviendrai là-dessus
parce que je pense que prennent des
états des États-Unis excusez-moi pèse
très lourd les conséquences de cette de
cette situation c'est de temps en temps
ces produits sont pas mis à disposition
soit parce qu'ils sont refusés par les
autorités réglementaires comme trop cher
soit comme l'Europe est plus dure que
les États-Unis les industriels se
retirent du marché européen c'était le
cas par homme de la société Bluebird qui
commercialise certains médicaments
thérapies géniques qui ne vend son
produit qu'aux États-Unis
donc tout ceci n'est pas il y a même des
domaines mon domaine celui des défis
immunitaires reditaires où il se trouve
malheureusement qu'une société à un
moment donné s'est retrouvée en quasi
monopole des trois médicaments
disponibles et à la décida tout arrêter
et c'est moi que c'était pas assez
rentable et donc il n'y a plus de
médicaments disponible aujourd'hui pour
ces maladies alors il y a des
alternatives graphe le moelle osseuse
etc c'est pas une catastrophe
heureusement pour les malades moi c'est
comme c'est pas une bonne nouvelle c'est
beaucoup de jeux à titre personnel qui
était beaucoup impliqué dans ces travaux
de recherche et à 20 ans encore plus
récemment c'est une certaine frustration
et si on réfléchit maintenant en se
projetant à l'avenir il y a une étude
qui est assez intéressante d'un institut
de recherche économique américain qui a
la SR qui est évidemment indépendant
l'industrie pharmaceutique ils ont fait
une étude publiée à maintenant 5-6 ans
mais à mon avis qui reste complètement
juste ils avaient le calcul que si on
mettait au point on est content que les
thérapies géniques dans le panne toutes
les autres thérapeutiques une thérapie
génique 1% des maladies génétiques 1% on
en est loin évidemment aujourd'hui au
prix de 1 million ce qui est sous-estimé
puisqu'on est plutôt à deux trois
millions aujourd'hui ça ça reviendrait
par an à d'augmenter le budget de
médicaments de tiers uniquement ça donc
c'est intenable sur la distance
totalement il y a les références si vous
souhaitez de tout ça donc voilà ça c'est
le constat que je fais effectivement que
j'ai eu l'occasion en partie d'écrire
vous avez fait allusion à des textes
publiés déjà et malheureusement il y a
plusieurs années ceci on n'a pas
vraiment changé si ce n'est cette
alourdi donc en termes de proposition
brièvement moi je pense qu'il faut
essayer vous l'avez dit très bien il
faut rassembler deux objectifs d'un côté
rendre ses médicaments accessibles au
moins dans des pays comme les nôtres je
parle malheureusement pas des pays du
tiers-monde pour lesquels la situation
est loin d'être satisfaisante y compris
pour des maladies fréquentes de parmi
celles que j'ai cité pour l'exemple la
drépanocytos par exemple en Afrique
centrale
et donc première objectif
l'accessibilité aux patients français si
on reste dans le pour de chez nous et
deuxièmement il faut maintenir
évidemment le savoir-faire l'incitation
et le développement par l'industrie de
médicaments on a besoin d'industrie donc
il faut injuste simplement il faut un
équilibre mon point de vue aujourd'hui
on n'est pas à l'équilibre le curseur
est allé progressivement trop loin en
faveur des bénéfices d'industrie
pharmaceutiques je reviendrai et ceci
est difficile il faut pas se faire
d'illusions même si on peut évoquer
quelques points je pense que évidemment
le marché du médicament il est mondial
et comme vous le savez certainement il y
a pratiquement pas de régulation des
prix aux États-Unis un tout petit peu
mais il y a une tentative actuelle de
mais c'est par rapport à ce qui se passe
en Europe c'est ridicule mais si on
regarde c'est assez intéressant ce que
dans les journaux américains qui sont
aujourd'hui pas avare de papiers sur
cette question nous avons le New York
Journal of Medicine publie des articles
l'un après l'autre sur cette question
mais qui considère presque l'Europe
comme une situation
idyllique enfin j'exagère alors pourtant
elle ne l'est pas par rapport aux
États-Unis c'est évidemment moins il
faut savoir que le prix des médicaments
aux États-Unis c'est en moyenne 2 à 3
fois le prix en Europe et c'est un
problème pour l'Europe parce que du coup
l'industrie a un levier de pression en
disant comme l'a fait la société
blueborne même si le marché européen est
très important à la limite je vais
vendre mes médicaments aux États-Unis à
tous les cas et le prix Les prix très
élevé au met des médicaments aux
États-Unis tirent vers le haut les prix
même chez nous et évidemment nous
n'avons aucun moyen de pression pour
intervenir sur les prix des médicaments
aux États-Unis si ce n'est espérer que
les choses finissent par évoluer il y a
une prise de conscience il y a beaucoup
de papiers la communauté médicale est
assez clairement au fait de cela il y a
je sais que
au sein au moins du Parti démocrate aux
États-Unis il y a des une volonté
d'avancer mais aujourd'hui c'est pas le
cas donc c'est un problème sérieux
peut-être le problème le plus difficile
et qui nous échappe qui vous échappe et
encore plus à moi donc les quelques
points néanmoins qu'on peut essayer
d'avancer
toute la négociation des prix Les prix
tout est complètement opaque
c'est la volonté que je comprends un peu
mais qui ne finait je pensais n'est pas
bonne du CEPS ou comme vous savez
sûrement même mieux que moi les on ne
connaît pas les prix négociés il y a des
rabais etc etc mais je pense que c'est
pas une bonne situation
ainsi évidemment l'OMS conduit une
résolution en mai 2009 mais
malheureusement qui n'est pas qui n'est
simplement comme on dit consulter afin
de c'est pas de consultatif mais enfin
qui ne s'impose pas aux états de en
faveur de la transparence des systèmes
de fixation des prix et des prix et je
crois qu'il finit la transparence enfin
vu du côté public la transparence
serait quand même mieux que l'opacité
l'opacité permet d'obtenir des rabais je
crois que dans certains cas ils sont
vraiment importants néanmoins
dans le système d'opacité
les négociateurs publics sont pas en
situation favorable parce que
l'industrie elle part des finitions il
connaît les prix de vente dans tous les
pays
et le négociateur public le CEPS pour la
France il connaît le prix en France et
c'est une situation de déséquilibre de
négociation qui n'est pas favorable même
si il y a des dans la notion
d'égociation des prix je sais que ça
repose sur les prix dans les autres pays
enfin c'est un peu compliqué mais c'est
pas une bonne fondamentalement pourquoi
dans ce domaine-là les il doit y avoir
une opacité donc la question c'est
finalement qu'elle devrait être les
critères de fixation des prix et dans un
monde idéal on pourrait rêver je suis
pas totalement naïf mais qu'il y ait une
qu'on met autour de la table les
industriels les parties prenantes les
payeurs et idéalement une échelle
internationale pour contenu de ce que
j'ai dit et qui fasse peut-être en
fonction du type de médicament un centre
de nos paramètres qui prennent en compte
bon les coûts de Recherche et
Développement évidemment qui existent
les coups de marketing qui sont plus
importants que les coûts de Recherche et
Développement même s'ils le disent pas
mais il y a quand même quelques études
qui le montrent les bénéfices il faut il
doit y avoir un bénéfice mais quel est
le niveau du bénéfice de l'industriel et
la fameuse valeur ajoutée j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure qu'il faut prendre en
compte mais qu'il ne peut pas être
l'élément unique et qui fait qui crée ce
déséquilibre à mon avis qui n'est pas
bon il y a un troisième point je
voudrais évoquer c'est je l'ai déjà
mentionné brièvement c'est tenir compte
de l'apport académique donc encore une
fois la plupart de ces médicaments
viennent du monde académique et le
retour sur investissement vers le monde
académique est très insuffisant
académique au sens large j'ai ajouté
l'exemple de la myotrophie spinale et
l'AFM et parlant et je crois que la fn
touche 15 millions d'euros par an
royalties pour un médicament qui est
vendu 1,9 millions d'euros par malade et
qui rappelant des bénéfices à nos
artistes colossal donc là il y a un
déséquilibre est une certaine façon nous
citoyens contribua nous payons deux fois
on paye la recherche
académique et on repeint le médicament
très cher
donc ceci n'est pas un avis pas
satisfaisant quatrième point c'est au
moins envisagé on peut pas envisager de
négociation des prix mondiales ça n'a
pas de sens mais il y a quand même un il
me semble un niveau où on pourrait
réfléchir c'est la Communauté européenne
aujourd'hui quand vous savez les chaque
pays enfin pas tout à fait chaque pays
mais la France négocie toute seule
certains petits pays entre guillemets
par la taille se sont au niveau européen
ce sont mis ensemble je crois qu'il y a
deux sous-ensembles ou inégocient
ensemble parce qu'ils sentent un tout
petit peu moins seul et peut-être un peu
moins faible mais pourquoi ne pas
imaginer que la même façon qu'il y a une
agence européenne du médicament pour la
validation et la mission le marché et
ben que il y a une extension disons
l'Agence européenne du médicament qui
négocie les prix quitte ce qui est des
péréquations pour les pays moins riches
après tout il y a un exemple où c'est un
marché et ça même très bien marché c'est
des vaccins anti sarcope 2 qui ont été
achetés après négociation par
l'Union européenne et moi je trouve que
c'est un exemple
qu'il faudrait suivre peut-être pas pour
tous les médicaments mais pour les
médicaments innovants onéreux ça c'est
une proposition voilà après on peut
encore discuter avec des maladies rares
et abandonner l'industrie on essaie de
mettre en place des structures à but non
lucratives de production de médicaments
au moins dans ce cadre là peut-être un
peu plus mais ça applique un
investissement initial public sans doute
avec l'aide de fondation et du milieu
caritatif peut encore imaginer d'autres
d'autres systèmes en tout état de cause
pour conclure sur ce point de la de
l'accessibilité des médicaments liés à
leur prix
je pense que l'évolution est
indispensable on va dans le mur à terme
pas immédiat mais même si aujourd'hui
les prix sont à peu près l'enveloppe de
prix ne dépense de médicaments en France
et contenu mais les contenus parce qu'on
a créé une nouvelle enveloppe ça c'est
un peu artificiel
je sais plus comment ça s'appelle le nom
de m'échappe mais c'est pas grave le
risque c'est que s'il y a pas une
évolution mais qui implique une
négociation entre le monde public et ind
logiciel pour l'intérêt des deux de mon
point de vue c'est qu'on aille vers une
situation américaine c'est à dire ceux
qui peuvent payer paye et les autres
voilà c'est pas accessible alors tout
dernier point je voudrais évoqué même si
c'est pas mon domaine mais j'ai lu un
peu notamment une référence que je vous
donner si vous l'avez pas parce qu'elle
est très explicite c'est est-ce que tout
ce que je raconte n'est pas une utopie
autrement dit est-ce que la situation
économique de l'industrie fait que c'est
pas possible qui peuvent pas réduire
leur leur prix encore une fois je suis
pas un économiste donc j'avance très
prudemment sur ces questions mais il y a
quand même plusieurs publications qui
montrent que fondamentalement les
bénéfices d'abord un club les bénéfices
du secteur pharmaceutique sont plus
importants que tous les bénéfices de
tous les autres secteurs industriels qui
sont au-dessus j'avais fait un travail à
l'époque avec un économiste belge qui
m'avait montré cela et avec des
références tout à fait ok que par
ailleurs les dépenses j'ai déjà évoqué
mais les il y a une étude récente sur 15
grandes entreprises mondiales les Big
Pharma qui montrent que les dépenses de
marketing ce qu'on peut estimer sont
largement supérieurs aux dépenses de
recherche et développement et peut-être
ce qui est le plus significatif c'est
que si on a additionne enfin ce qui
correspond à la financialisation de ces
entreprises c'est clair qui est les
dividendes distribués et plus le Cher
bye bye c'est-à-dire le rachat des
actions par l'industriel ça représente
une somme d'argent supérieure aux
investissements recherchent et
développement donc franchement encore
une fois même si je ne suis pas
économiste il me semble qu'il y a un peu
de grains à moudre et qui a une marge de
négociation possible je vous incidament
je m'arrête là je vous suggère la
lecture si je peux me permettre d'une
d'un papier qui est je trouve assez
remarquable sur ce plan qui est un
article dont le premier hôtel s'appelle
Angelis ange à risque de son prénom qui
est paru dans le journal qui est le
British Medical Journal qui est paru
cette année si vous voulez noter la
référence précise allez il est vraiment
je très très explicite sur les aspects
économiques
voilà je m'arrête là peut-être puis on
continue
merci
c'est propos introductifs déjà très très
instructif et qui pose bien la question
je vais tout de suite passer la parole à
Lens Cohen pour rapporteur pour une
liste de questions
il y a effectivement plusieurs plusieurs
éléments et qui corroborent déjà les les
auditions que nous avons menées parce
que effectivement le prix est quelque
chose qui revient beaucoup mais pas le
prix en fait des médicaments innovants
en général c'est pas une grande part des
auditions que nous avons mais les
industriels se plaignent des des prix
trop bas des médicaments matures voilà
donc
on est dans une logique où ils appellent
et le LEM
les soutiens là-dessus à réévaluer les
prix des médicaments matures or les
exemples que nous avons eu durant nos
auditions c'est que alors que les prix
sont plus élevés en Allemagne ou encore
en Suisse ces pays ont souffert des
pénuries donc ça n'est pas les qui qui
sont
qui seraient facteurs de pénurie alors
en même temps il faut passer simplifier
le débat c'est vrai que les pénuries
sont multifactorielles et il y a
plusieurs plusieurs éléments mais voilà
donc c'est important effectivement de
voir comment est-ce qu'on peut arrêter
un peu cette
cette course dans l'évolution des prix
où effectivement il y a une envolée des
prix des prix innovants et avec avec pas
de j'allais dire pas de rendu du service
c'est à dire que quel que soit
finalement les facilités que peuvent
mettre en place les gouvernements c'est
ce que vous avez dit d'une autre façon
il y a pas de retour quoi
par exemple et c'est là-dessus que je
voudrais vous interroger c'est
concernant le cri le crédit impôt
recherche le sien bon à la fois on a eu
dans les dans les auditions le qui nous
a été dit que c'était vraiment
facteur d'attractivité et que on a
entendu ce matin en allant à Bercy que
ça représentait quand même un
investissement extrêmement important
pour l'État français puisque c'est de
l'ordre de 7 milliards à peu près un
grosso modo mais en même temps
les mêmes entreprises pour certaines
d'entre elles vont optimiser
pudiquement appelé le crédit impôt
recherche pour échapper
au fait que ils vont devoir produire sur
le marché français et donc pour
rechercher une rentabilité maximale donc
qu'est-ce que vous vous pensez
qu'il serait possible de faire par
exemple est-ce qu'il ne serait pas
important de de mettre un certain nombre
de critères par rapport aux crédits pour
recherche c'est à dire par exemple
dans mon environnemental et des normes
sociales et à ce moment-là y compris
d'ailleurs peut-être valoriser les
mettre un label en quelque sorte de
souveraineté par rapport aux industriels
qui respectent ces normes
environnementales sociales mais
également de production au niveau du
territoire français ou on peut pas tout
relocaliser mais en tout cas au minimum
européen pour rapprocher donc ça c'est
ma c'est ma deuxième question ma
troisième question vous l'avez un petit
peu abordé où vous avez évoqué l'idée de
la mise en place d'un petit nombre de
structures à but non lucratif afin de
produire des lots de thérapie génique
voir des médicaments au moins des
maladies très rares dont le financement
serait assuré par les États et de
grandes fondations privées telles la
Ligue contre le cancer par exemple
c'était un exemple que vous avez donné
mais il y en aurait d'autres
effectivement nous nous sommes amenés
dans les auditions que que nous que nous
avons faites à réfléchir au fait que au
moins pour une liste de médicaments
courtes
établi mais de manière disons on va dire
les médicaments critiques il y a une
possibilité qu'il y ait une production
publique
et qui se fasse peut-être en lien avec
les pharmacies
hospitalières centrales que ce soit au
niveau de la PHP ou de la PHM etc etc et
qui pourraient bénéficier de moyens
financiers et humains pour pouvoir le
faire alors il s'agit pas pour nous
d'avoir comme idée tout d'un coup parce
qu'elles ont été dépourvues de leur d'un
certain nombre de d'éléments et
notamment en termes de personnel de
produits mais via la sous-traitance etc
elle pourrait produire
qu'en pensez-vous est-ce que vous pensez
que ça peut être une une solution et la
quatrième enfin quatrième question ça
concerne en fait le pilotage
parce que on a eu l'impression je vais
le dire rapidement pour être clair c'est
que en termes de médicaments il y avait
pas de pilote dans l'avion vraiment et
qu'à un moment donné il y a beaucoup de
d'agences qui font leur travail etc mais
à un moment donné la réponse la le
donneur d'ordre si je puis dire ça doit
être le le gouvernement ça doit être le
politique et donc ministère de la Santé
ministère de la Santé par exemple et
enfin la toute dernière question ça
concerne la recherche
puisque vous en avez beaucoup parlé mais
c'est vrai que au niveau de la recherche
il y a une part très importante donc de
recherche avec des financements publics
mais ça n'a pas entraîné une comment
dirais-je un apport privé pour cette
même cette même recherche derrière il y
a un déséquilibre entre le financement
public et le financement privé en termes
de recherche est-ce que ça vous
vous le vous le partagez ou pas et en
tout cas comment est-ce qu'on peut faire
en sorte que ça soit
différent et que quand il y a
investissement en tout cas public comme
c'est le cas il est un retour une espèce
de c'est quand même des quelque part des
missions de service public qui doivent
être redonnés voilà les cinq questions
que je voulais vous poser je vous
remercie moi je rajouterai une c'est
dans votre propos liminaire vous avez
évoqué des thérapies qui ont été
arrêtées par un laboratoire
alors qu'elles avaient un intérêt
thérapeutique un service médical rendu
majeur voilà et donc
est-ce que
d'abord confirmé que le fait qu'elle
soit arrêtée soit un vrai problème pour
la santé publique même s'il y a des
alternatives je pense que la greffe
c'est pas forcément enfin c'est pas
exactement la même chose voilà donc il y
a aussi des effets secondaires voilà
différents
et que pensez-vous de l'obligation de
remettre le brevet en ce cas quand le
risque finalement sanitaire est avéré
j'essaie de reprendre dans l'ordre
j'espère que j'ai bien noté crédit impôt
recherche effectivement qui représente
un montant non négligeable de l'un de 7
milliards
ce qui me rend un peu perplexe c'est que
si on regarde les dépenses de recherche
en France elles sont à peu près elle
représente 2,2% du PIB à peu près
c'est un peu moins de 0,8 pour le public
et un peu plus d'un 4 pour le privé si
on regarde en arrière en 2008 on a les
chiffres sont les mêmes en France c'est
à dire que par rapport au PIB la part de
des dépenses de recherche en France n'a
pas progressé donc on est loin de
l'objectif qui avait été fixé dans les
années 90 à la fameuse conférence de
Lisbonne l'Union européenne qui était la
teinte 3%. il est intéressant de se
comparer à l'Allemagne entre autres mais
on peut se qu'on peut à d'autres pays
l'Allemagne était en 2008 environ je
parle de mémoire mais je pense que c'est
juste vous pouvez vérifier facilement
avec le même fraction du PIB consacré à
la recherche et après avec les mêmes
pourcentages publics privés et
aujourd'hui l'Allemagne a dépassé
l'objectif des 3%. et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que la croissance
publique et privée sont complètement
parallèles donc est-ce que peut dire que
là strictement entraîné l'autre il faut
être toujours prudent mais enfin le
constat c'est que le aujourd'hui en
public ils sont 1,1 je sais plus
exactement et en privé donc fait la
différence à neuf c'est que c'est
toujours un rapport 1 à 2 environ mais
mais les deux ont progressé
parallèlement et il y a eu un effort en
gros c'est le mandat de Madame Merkel
mais je crois que c'est possible et
c'est poursuivi la mandature actuelle de
façon très progressive d'augmenter les
crédits de recherche et en le faisant
intelligemment entrer dans les détails
mais ils ont fait des programmes
permettant développer ce que c'est bien
d'avoir des crédits mais il faut bien
les utiliser aussi c'est une évidence et
ils ont fait un magnifique travail et
qui se traduit je pense j'en suis sûr
par une recherche qui aujourd'hui à des
performances supérieures à la nôtre mais
peut-être aussi en termes de médicaments
et le covid a montré même si je peux pas
établir avec certitude une relation de
cause à effet donc à quoi sert le crédit
pour recherche en France alors si je
veux avoir une vision un peu cynique
c'est à dire s'il y avait pas le crédit
pour recherche on serait même pas stable
on serait en décroissant je ne sais pas
mais dans tous les cas il n'a pas permis
d'augmenter la part du PIB privé
consacré à la recherche ce qui est
évidemment dommage alors mettre des
critères je pense que
j'aurais assez envie de penser que que
les entreprises qui pourraient le mieux
bénéficier du crédit pour recherche on
les entreprises petites et moyennes qui
sont quand même pas qui n'ont pas les
mêmes situations financières que les Big
Pharma si on reste dans le domaine de la
pharmacie mais cela dit ça s'applique
évidemment à d'autres domaines donc
j'aurais plutôt tendance à je ne sais
pas exactement selon quel critère mais
favoriser l'utilisation de ce crédit un
peu recherche par les entreprises qui ne
sont pas des les très grosses sanofies
mais l'entendre mais aussi je sais pas
Thalès ou d'autres dans des domaines qui
n'ont rien à voir avec la santé par
exemple je suis assez
sensible à ce que vous proposez à l'idée
de mettre des liens en tous les cas des
conditions supplémentaires genre de
nature différente 3 l'emploi des
thésards
que ces gens emploie les gens qui ont
fait une thèse de science qui est
toujours un problème en France qui n'est
pas résolu notamment les gens qui ont
des thèses en sciences de la vie avec
une inclusion très inégale et très
insuffisante encore de la thèse dans les
conventions collectives
des clauses ce que je reviens sur la
discute un tout petit peu tout à l'heure
des clauses de prix raisonnables ou de
d'accord
satisfaisant lorsqu'il y a transfert
dans des négociations entre le monde
académique et privé et puis pourquoi pas
une part de production française moi je
dirais européenne pour être plus
réaliste à mon avis ça me choquerait pas
transparence vous avez évoqué les normes
sociales énormément environnementales ça
m'a fait penser à quelque chose que je
connais pas bien mais dont j'ai entendu
parler qui est pas inintéressant mais
dont j'ai peur que ça soit quand même
pas une solution simple c'est le statut
d'entreprise à mission
qui s'est développée relativement aux
États-Unis que prenaient beaucoup une
ex-candidate aux élections
présidentielles américaines Elisabeth
Moron notamment d'ailleurs pour
l'industrie pharmaceutique l'idée étant
pour les c'est ce qui a essayé de faire
un grand industriel qui a perdu son
poste de PDG Gobain
non non
et j'ai oublié le nom de quelqu'un qui
est très connu mais qui a perdu il y a
deux trois ans son poste de PDG il a
essayé de
transformer Danone en entreprise à
mission donc l'entreprise a mission
c'est une entreprise qui est
indépendamment des des
nécessité de faire des bénéfices et que
les actionnaires soient en soi satisfait
soit satisfait il y a aussi d'autres
objectifs qui sont d'ordre sociaux donc
ça peut être énorme environnementale les
normes sociales ça peut être aussi pour
l'industrie du médicament les prix des
médicaments s'engager à des prix
raisonnables c'est pas une affaire
simple il y a tout
une liste de ditems à remplir il y a
quelques entreprises qui sont au-delà de
Danone qui n'est pas dans le domaine qui
nous concerne directement tous les cas
aujourd'hui bon c'est peut-être une vue
l'esprit parce que est-ce que après tout
ce thème entreprise accepteraient de
modérer leurs prix je ne sais pas mais
ça rentre quand même peut-être un peu
dans la réflexion
bon les questions de transparence par
ailleurs je vais abordé tout à l'heure
et mais c'est évident que toutes les
autres normes doivent intervenir
les productions de médicaments dans des
dans un contexte non lucratif d'avoir
des exemples où ça marche de prendre
deux exemples opposés j'ai oublié le nom
de l'entreprise aux États-Unis mais il y
a un certain nombre de pitos américains
ce sont mis ensemble pour créer une
telle société à but non lucratif qui
produit des médicaments en pénurie ils
ont aussi ce problème comme vous le
savez aux États-Unis j'ai oublié le nom
mais ça existe je sais pas une échelle
très importante mais ça existe et à
l'opposé pour les médicaments très
innovants l'hôpital val-ebronn à
Barcelone développe ses propres cartis
Celtes sur un plan juridique et limite
et mais le prix auquel s'est facturé au
malade donc aux assurances sociales en
Espagne là où c'est 400.000 euros en
France et moins de 100.000 euros en
Espagne
donc on peut y arriver ils ont monté
leur production et une qualité
pharmaceutique indiscutable il s'agit
pas évidemment de transiger d'aucune
façon avec la qualité des médicaments ça
c'est impossible à imaginer une seconde
donc c'est à dire que c'est faisable pas
simple mais c'est faisable donc il y a
effectivement deux axes il y a l'axe des
médicaments courants en pénurie
et l'axe des médicaments innovants le
plus compliqué mais je pense que c'est
pas complètement impossible et on peut
pas avancer massivement dans ces
domaines moi je suis assez favorable à
ce que ces deux axes soient explorés
il faut faire des études économiques sur
les coûts de mise en place etc quels
sont les fondations les vous avez évoqué
la Ligue contre le cancer on pourrait
pour la France on pourrait évoquer l'AFM
qui a des structures qui s'en
rapprochent
il y a je pense que c'est certainement
une piste à explorer qui va pas résoudre
par miracle toutes les problèmes mais
qui pourraient ensemble de questions il
est important de que de montrer en
espérant que ça soit le cas que c'est
ces entreprises sont efficientes
qu'elles ont la qualité qu'elles peuvent
le faire à des prix raisonnables mais si
la preuve de principe est apportée après
on peut avancer un peu plus et donc
mettre peut-être de temps en temps se
mettre en compétition avec l'industrie
et encore les prêtres de brevet c'est
pas complètement ça mais je pense que ce
type de choses à mon avis à nouveau
devait être réfléchi discuté à l'échelle
européenne je pense qu'on partage avec
nos voisins les mêmes problématiques que
ce soit les pénuries de médicaments vous
l'avez évoqué ou la problématique des
prix des médicaments innovants et je
pense que
l'approche rationnelle et la plus
efficiente serait de s'associer de
s'allier avec les Italiens les Allemands
etc et de faire ensemble je pense que ce
serait
plus rentable
quatrième question pilotage de la
politique du médicament qu'est-ce que
vous entendez par le pilotage la
politique vous excluez la recherche à ce
stade là je pense c'est sur le les
stratégies de production les besoins
prioritaires ce genre de choses donc ça
rejoint le capacités de production
S qui souhaitent qui puisse être remises
à disposition à proximité en France ou
en Europe oui effectivement forcément
les pouvoirs publics ont un mot à dire
mais il faut reconnaître que ce sont les
industriels qui produisent ce sont eux
qui ont le savoir-faire et donc ça doit
être une négociation avec eux je pense
que ça n'avait beaucoup discuté
j'imagine avec Sanofi et d'autres
bien sûr il faut qu'il y ait une
politique de médicaments est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui
je suis pas capable je connais pas assez
bien je vais dire des bêtises je suis
pas capable d'apprécier le niveau de
perception ou d'action plus important du
ministère de la Santé en particulier sur
cette question je préfère m'abstenir je
connais pas assez bien regarde bêtises
essayez de pas dire trop de bêtises la
recherche dépense publique déséquilibres
publiques privées alors la réponse est
en fait non il y a pas un déséquilibre
il y a pas assez des deux
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure la
comparaison avec l'Allemagne et on
pourrait reprendre celle avec les pays
performants en recherche en Europe sans
aller aux États-Unis au Canada en Corée
au Japon sont tous les pays du Nord la
Belgique les Pays-Bas la Grande-Bretagne
la Scandinavie en gros et dans ces pays
là donc il y a des dépenses de recherche
sont globalement supérieurs c'est à
nouveau si on se rapporte au PIB et
elles sont supérieures du côté public et
du côté privé et le ratio c'est assez
intéressant et finalement assez constant
partout il y a des nuances mais vraiment
assez faible à ces chiffres sont
facilement disponibles donc je pense que
ce n'est pas une question déséquilibrée
c'est qu'il y a des montants des crédits
de recherche qui sont insuffisants en
pub dans le domaine public et dans le
domaine privé mais en même temps on
pourrait développer plus longtemps ce
n'est pas qu'une question d'argent c'est
aussi une question d'organisation de
choix stratégiques aujourd'hui par
exemple je trouve qu'on met trop
l'accent même s'il faut le faire c'est
important surtout dans toutes les
questions qu'on évoque sur le soutien à
l'innovation à travers le France 2030 et
spécifiquement l'agence d'innovation
santé pour ce qui compte ne concerne le
domaine qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui
mais il y a pas assez d'argent vers
l'amant vers la recherche si on veut
innover il faut d'abord trouver ça peut
un peu c'est un tout petit peu primaire
de dire ça mais c'est quand même juste
et je pense que on est un peu trop en
déséquilibre sur ce plan mais donc quand
même quand encore une fois ce n'est pas
qu'un problème public c'est aussi un
problème privé mais j'ai envie de penser
que comme on l'a vu en Allemagne
possiblement l'un peut tirer l'autre
s'il y a une dynamique qui s'instaurait
il faut on a une difficulté en France
c'est que le monde même si ça va mieux
que ça a été dans le passé je crois mais
il y a quand même le monde public et le
monde privé sont des mondes qui ne se
connaissent pas assez bien alors c'est
pas le cas dans la plupart des autres
pays pour des raisons à mon avis qui
sont liées à la formation des gens parce
que dans les autres nous avons une
grande spécificité
diversion mais c'est lié au beau sujet
qui concerne le fait nous avons un
système universitaire dual entre les
grandes écoles et les universités et en
gros les dirigeants d'entreprise et les
dirigeants politiques sont viennent d'un
système de grandes écoles avec en
général peu de formation scientifique au
passage et les scientifiques viennent
plutôt l'université plus quelques
grandes écoles spécialisées comme
l'École normale supérieure un tout petit
peu lixe et encore pas tant que ça et si
on demande donc il sépare le 18 ans il
se connaissent plus ça peut paraître je
caricature évidemment mais néanmoins
c'est quand même je pense que ce sont
des mondes qui s'ignorent qui n'ont pas
qui du coup sont défiance relatives
alors que vous allez en Allemagne en
Grande-Bretagne dans ces pays tous ces
gens là ont été dans les mêmes
universités alors pas dans les mêmes
filières mais ils se sont côtoyés ils se
connaissent il se passe des coups de fil
beaucoup plus il se parlent beaucoup
plus que que ce qui se passe dans le
système français c'est pas facile d'y
remédier
il y a au moins un aspect qu'on peut
faire remarquer c'est que la formation
parle la recherche de des ingénieurs et
beaucoup plus faibles en France qu'en
Allemagne les ingénieurs allemands ont
quatre fois plus souvent que ça gère en
français une thèse de sciences c'est pas
dire qu'ils veulent tous faire de la
recherche scientifique mais ça veut dire
qu'ils ont une culture scientifique et
ça va jusqu'au politique Madame Merkel
avait fait de la chimie une thèse de
chimie je pense que ça a joué dans sa
volonté de développer la recherche
pardon je m'arrête sur cette parenthèse
le dernier point
c'est pas simple cette histoire de
d'arrêt de production de produits
innovants alors c'est vrai que c'est la
société hors chart qui a une petite
société britannique qui avait développé
qui a racheté ses produits etc et
finalement comme elle a un médicament
pour une autre maladie qui où il y a là
c'est il y a pas d'alternative du tout
et qu'il vendent deux fois plus cher
pour ce qu'on appelle une mucopolis à
carridose Humanis surcharge ils ont
choisi de développer cette thérapie là
beaucoup plus
rentable que les défiscitaires là c'est
vrai qu'il y a une petite perte en
charge honnêtement aujourd'hui parce
qu'il y a eu des progrès des grèves de
moelle osseuse c'est moins je veux là il
y a 10 ans je vous aurais dit c'est une
catastrophe aujourd'hui je dis que c'est
moins grave effectivement se pose la
question parce qu'on peut on peut
l'extrapoler à d'autres domaines
qu'est-ce qui se passe ici un produit
n'est plus développé alors qu'il a un
intérêt médical indiscutable je pense
que c'est des situations on peut
imaginer d'intervenir pour faire en
sorte que c'est ce produit puisse être
produit y compris dans les structures
non lucratif pourquoi pas le racheter
les la des prix raisonnables les droits
sur ces produits c'est éventuellement
envisageable pas simple mais peut pas
être fait à grande échelle mais au cas
par cas c'est pareil
ce que vous souhaitez apporter des
éléments complémentaires
j'ai rien à dire de qu'il soit
intéressant pour vous parce que je
connais pas assez bien cette histoire
des brevets est un vrai sujet parce que
on voit bien que la stratégie des grands
laboratoires et quand même finalement
ou de trouver quelqu'un d'autre pour
fabriquer des produits matures ou
d'arrêter tout court en tout cas c'est
une espèce de logique qu'on voit se
dessiner et les pays dans la les
facteurs des pénuries on voit bien que
c'est
cette
responsabilité là est importante
je pense qu'il faut quand même vraiment
distinguer la situation des médicaments
médicament courant qui coûte pas très
cher des médicaments innovants c'est
vraiment de évidemment c'est
complètement connecté puisqu'on est même
producteurs
mais en termes de démarche
sont quand même de deux situations assez
différentes
[Musique]
ça représente une force de recherche
économique politique importante et je
pense que agir sur toutes ces questions
à l'échelle de l'Europe que ce soit sur
les pénuries sur les médicaments
innovants une certaine façon sur la
recherche
je pense que l'Union européenne ferait
beaucoup mieux que chacun des pays c'est
vraiment un domaine où l'Union
européenne peut à une valeur ajoutée à
mon avis considérable mais bon c'est mon
point de vue
la question du même s'il est moins
régulé qu'en France le prix du
médicament des pénuries sont présentes
également et puis il y a aussi pour
régler des questions d'accès qui
rapportent de l'argent
et on voit bien qu'il y a eu un souci de
aussi
pour des raisons de l'accessibilité pour
l'insuline par exemple il y a eu une
tentative de régulation du prix de
l'insuline est vendu à des prix
exorbitance exorbitant
donc on est face à une pathologie qui
est quand même relativement fréquente
mais on s'aperçoit par exemple hier on a
on a on a auditionné un membre de la
fiou Cruz au Brésil et on s'est aperçu
dans la façon dont il nous a
décrit la situation alors Brésil pays
continent 220 millions d'habitants on
n'est pas sur la même échelle mais
continue de ce qu'ils ont fait par
rapport au VIH et de la présence de la
fille aux Cruz la fiou Cruz elle est
capable de faire de la recherche
de produire des médicaments et de les
distribuer donc à partir de ce moment là
elle a quand même un pouvoir de réaction
et d'action extrêmement considérable
alors que ce que ce qu'on s'est dit
depuis le début ensemble c'est que
le gouvernement français mais pas que le
gouvernement français mais pour ce qui
nous intéresse et quand même tributaire
des décisions qui vont prendre
les industriels et c'est ça c'est pour
ça que je j'ai remis un peu dans la
course les parce que je ne vois pas
d'autres d'autres possibilités les
pharmacies centrales au niveau
hospitalier parce que elles peuvent
éventuellement mais elles ont été
beaucoup des armées il y a du boulot
quand même voilà mais oui c'est une
toute petite base mais parce qu'il faut
il faut il faut partir de quelque chose
mais comme il y a pas la volonté moi je
vois bien entre le moment on est en 2023
et le moment où je suis je suis élue en
2011 je vois tous les moyens que la GEP
par exemple a perdu elle est plus en
capacité de produire aujourd'hui elle
passe par la sous-traitance par d'autres
voilà donc si vous voulez au fur et à
mesure quand on se donne pas les moyens
on les a pas
si je peux un petit commentaire sur le
Brésil et l'Inde aussi sont des pays qui
en est des structures de production
médicament ou de vaccin par ailleurs
mais c'est un médicament aussi
de très performant et ça leur permet au
point des médicaments courants et des
médicaments pour lesquels
les brevets sont tombés etc etc d'avoir
accès à des prix raisonnables à des
médicaments restent que ils ont le même
problème avec les médicaments innovants
la recherche brésilienne n'est pas telle
elle n'est pas dans les malheureusement
pour eux les médicaments innovants
aujourd'hui ils viennent pas du Brésil
ils viennent les États-Unis ils viennent
un peu l'Europe mais bon donc ça permet
d'assurer typiquement les médicaments du
VIH qui est hyper important évidemment
ou un certain nombre d'agents
anti-infectueux dont ils ont besoin etc
mais c'est il y a quand même une limite
aussi c'est c'est
juste préciser ça
ils ont l'intelligence de développer des
coopérations avec la France avec
l'Institut Pasteur avec un certain
nombre donc il ils sont quand même dans
une démarche qui peut aboutir et donc et
comme ils ont les outils après pour pour
développer ils ont quand même réussi par
exemple par rapport à la force leur
marché à récupérer toute la
technologie de la messager et de pouvoir
c'est quand même excusez-moi mais là je
dirais avoir
ils ont ils ont produit massivement et
c'est très bien le vaccin d'AstraZeneca
etc mais après ce qu'ils peuvent
développer par eux-mêmes ensuite
d'autres choses sortir du Sark of 2 et
transposer une autre maladie infectieuse
je pense qu'ils n'ont pas cette
technologie aujourd'hui malheureusement
pour eux s'ils peuvent effectivement
produire en ils savent très bien
produire en masse ce qui est bien l'Inde
aussi cette capacité
l'Egypte je sais pas oui c'est peut-être
je sais pas encore OK
merci beaucoup je vous en prie pour cet
échange très instructif